So, your daughter had to leave your house at 17 cuz you and your
ex-wife are such losers.
I got it. This is a guy who screams about how rich people are
like 8 hours a day and he feels so uncomfortable at watching
how badly Will got in front of him. Like, he's actually so
And they're like, "That's with the dis pick that up, mate. God
damn. What the is wrong with you? Are you really yelling at me
about that, Bill? You're getting kicked off the island. Wanted
to put him in a bad spot considering the way you treated me.
Considering the way you feed Willie, how how would I put him
in spot if he's already look like us? So he can turn around and
call him a sweeper a day later. Let's let's not be
Tommy Tommy she streamed. Yeah. Yeah, he streamed today and now
Collins from Lumpy Willie and Hellbent and one other guy, Perry,
I think. Yeah, I think so. Okay, so we could do the Tommy C stuff
real quick. I think it's probably going to be good. So I wouldn't
mind. He did like a whole stream today. I don't know if it's
Chud. He's taking callins on Chud. So, I was given this time
stamp said it was a told it was a good time to watch some of
his call-ins on Chud. People question him on like the timeline
on the video and there's a lot of questions. We'll see how it
goes. I'm very interested. And then we can go on to Israel stuff
after this, assuming that nobody gets me video of any actual
missiles striking Israel. Okay. I'm willing to look into this
if we've got stuff that like if Israel's getting hit, but uh
yeah, change title to World War II now. World War III now. World
War III
Uh hold on. Okay, I probably need to do this again. I mean, if
you think about it, if you think about it, World War it's like
it makes you think of apocalyptic, right? I think if you asked
me a year ago, it would have felt bizarre to be told that Warren
Smith is going to be on the Whatever podcast.
Yeah. Like why what's happening? I don't know. It's like a glitch.
He's uh he's
it'll certainly be interesting. I haven't gone through it though.
That's the only thing. So, while I do want to watch Warren Smith
on that podcast, also my title wouldn't change. Like I don't
know why this feels like the one person to be invited on one
of these podcasts where it's like more likely that he cries than
the women. Well, and also I did notice I cannot I don't know
if kicks down. I cannot update my title on kick is just freezing
when I go to update my title. So cool. You love to see it. Anyway,
I guess we'll just start on this Tommy C content. Yeah, we got
a Hassan laugh. Yeah, Stalin is sloth. I said, "I understand
that you're telling me that Msad's headquarters got hit, but
MSAD's headquarters, I don't have a video of it. I don't have
anything showing visuals of it getting hit. So, I'm waiting for
that." Did you see his five minute summary? Whose 5 minute summary
are we talking about? When? No, I did not. Maybe we can check
it out after, but for now, goodness, we're starting with the
Tommy C content. Okay, the Tommy Collins. We'll do that really
quick because that's just tying into a bunch of the stuff we've
done. All right, let's go. I'm going to get some water. I'm going
to get a drink here. I am going to make a rule set, but I'm also
going to play by your rules myself. In other words, if you give
me any respect, I will totally give you the same respect. If
you're going to troll or call me or anything like that, well,
fine. But here are the rules as follows. Number one, you cannot
ask me. I said my entire video series on Chud is being why I
don't trust him. Those are the reasons that I won't talk to him.
So, why won't you talk to Chud? you will get it instantly hung
up on instantly like that. Okay. Um you have to pick one topic.
Example, turkey tom bowback something I said. If um if you're
going to accuse me of something, have a time stamp. I'll see
to it right there and then. So that's the rules. If you break
them, get snippy with me or ju just uh just totally bad faith
or or scream or yell. I don't need to do this. doesn't mean that
no skin off my back.
So, pop on in. Yes, we did callull a bunch of people. People
are calling him a pedophile and saying I set my pig. It's the
same thing. Like, it's so much weird how these guys, all those
lefty losers on Chud's side are exactly like Andy Warski's side,
you know, peeing on kids. That was five years ago. Now, it's
sending 14y olds, you know. So,
this is your chance right now. You've had an hour to get clips,
everything.
Um, well, I'll be asking here. It work like this. Do you want
to debate me over the chat thing? Yes. Pick one subject. Somebody
is. And then I'm going to say, will you play by the rules? Somebody
is definitely calling this guy.
snippy. What's that? Well, I mean, come on. You should Yeah,
it is vague. I admit, but I mean Yeah. I mean, well, if you get
me, get me. If you're funny, I'll probably let you go. Hellbend's
first. All right, here we go. Oh, it's Rio. Rio called him a
obviously since that I called him a Then someone fake doned that
I was a so we could bond about it. So big things. Okay, Hellbent.
How are you? Hellbent.
Let's see the comedic chops. All right, we're going to see some
awesome comedy from Hellbent here. I can feel it. I can feel
it, Cherry. Don't you feel it? We're get some some awesome comedy.
This is going to be a very funny moment. I think so. Hello. Hey,
you there? Yeah. Can you hear me? Okay. Here's Are you here to
debate me over Chud? Oh, sure. Yes. Okay. Um, pick the topic.
This specific one, cuz I don't want people like flipping around
changing. All right. Uh, I have a theory and I have a question.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're choosing. No, no. You're choosing. Now you just want Now
you just want to answer. She's Russian.
I don't know exactly what accent is. She's Russian.
Russian who's lived in America before Russian
with a sense of humor.
Yeah. Okay. This is like two negatives make a positive. Maybe
like Russians have no humor. Women have no humor. Maybe a Russian
woman actually gains humor somehow. No. No. I'm a I'm a big fan
of Hellbent. I already like her. I believe that she's funny.
I'm just This is news to me that I have such confidence in a
Russian woman. Okay. Ask me a question. Correct. One question.
I will ask you. Uh, yeah. I would like to All right. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Jesus hell. Ben, you can't do that.
You You're going Yes. You're going to answer me a question, correct?
Yes. And you'll play by the rules. Yes or no? This is like actual
PTSD. Like he he's a veteran, right? Is this actual PTSD? Hellbent
literally just starts going, "Well, here's what I'd like to talk."
And he's like, "No, no, no, no. You can't do that. You can't
do that. You can't do that."
Yeah. Yes, I will play. But is it the Hellbent that you said
everyone hated that everybody hates on all the time? I don't
personally get it. I will make a joke about a woman not being
funny every day of the week. Well, that's what Quayman says.
Like you and Quiming because you guys see the chatters hate her.
No. Oh, sorry. Yeah, but like there are way other there are way
more people who like hate on Hellbent all the time. I think it's
too much personally. Yeah, Hellbent's always been nice to me.
Go ahead, ask your question. That's what we're going to do to
everybody. I just want to give an example. Everything that I've
seen from Hellbent makes her funnier than Jay Saka and Queen
put together. So, okay. Okay. Haters just going to hate. That's
your question. Okay. Sorry. What have you seen from Hellbat?
Nothing. So, I have a question uh in regard to what you said
earlier in this stream. I believe it was about how you
uh told somebody else uh to not talk to Aiden. Do you remember
that? Yeah. Do you would you not say that that is an example
of sneaky behavior? What? No.
because I told him he was a No, I I don't think so because I
thought I think Aiden was being a snake to this particular person.
Okay. So, if for example like if you are friends like Well, you're
friends with Matt and Matt Pit and Core, right? So, if Matt told
you, hey, don't speak to Core because I think he's just, you
know, actually a sneaky shifty.
Would that not feel weird to you being put in that? No, because
I'd asked him to back it up. I'm putting I'm putting a on that.
I'll do one more. I'll do one more and then there's a cool down.
Okay, I'm not gonna do it every like five seconds. Yeah, I don't
know about that. But also, what the [__] is wrong
with his chat? Why do his chatters ask him such weird cuz he
doesn't really have chatters and they're just all people in like
broadly the like spicy/c commentary community. Like it's it's
not his own people who ever chat in his chat. Okay, that's it
for like five minutes. Okay, just telling you. Uh yeah. So, cuz
your statement was that you told that person. I mean, I think
everyone has a pretty good guess of who that person It was easy
to back it up. His whole history is easy to back up. He's not
He's never been trustworthy. You can go back all the uh Yeah,
he's never been a trustworthy guy. I don't need to delete that.
Here, I'll I'll fix it. Porter Bell. I don't need to delete it.
I just need to make it more expensive. Way more expensive. Pass.
He got a pass when he was a kid because he was a kid. He was
a teenager. If you guys redeem
Kelly speaks, she we can get her here. Look at the situation
during election day. We got along real great. And I even said,
"Oh boy, you know, all grown up now. You're not like you used
to be. It's really great. I'm glad you're not hanging around
that comedy Jeff Holiday." And it was a really good time. And
then next he's hanging around people that are entertaining me
sending pics. So be clear, I'm not I'm not the No, I know. But
I'm answer I'm answering the best I can. No, no. I I actually
I'm not even going to dispute Aiden being shifty. He's He's a
shifty. I know.
Oh, what?
I've been sapping them all like Tommy C being anti-Semitic for
a while. I'm just glad to see people pick it up, start using
it. Good stuff.
I'm not saying that. I'm saying that. That's your Well, I'm not
saying that.
He's just He's just got He's got He just happens to have a problem
with all these people. This just a shitty YouTuber.
What? It just seems odd to me that
um because clearly like well I I just presume that the person
you were talking about was Nick. Uh I just it just seems odd
that you would take it upon yourself to tell
a mutual friend. Do you think you think it would first of all
I was done with it at the time. Um he just didn't know it. I'd
make a federal case of it. Do you think it's kind of shady to
warn somebody about your concerns?
And it's not like Nick wasn't aware of them. I think obviously
you're more than welcome to bring your concerns to this other
person. I suppose the reason why I wanted to question you on
this is because your phrasing was I told him not to talk to you
and yeah, I said I
tell you what I'll tell every Tommy C is just like
he's like uh what oh what's his name? Griema worm tongue in Nick's
ear. He's just like no don't talk to Aiden. Aiden's trying to
screw you. No, don't talk to Queenman. Queen's trying to screw.
No, don't talk to Jto. Don't talk to Chud. These people are trying
to hurt you. Nick, you have enemies on all sides. Nick, everybody
but me is an enemy. Everybody but me is an enemy. I At what point
is it like, okay, maybe not everybody was out to get Nick. I
don't know. Everybody knows Everybody knows who it is. He told
me something and I said, "Expect to see it in your next exposed
video." That's exactly what I said. I I suppose my point is like
it depends on what your intentions and expectations. My intention
was only somebody I've known for the better part of seven years
and somebody I've known that's been shifty in the past. That's
it. And I just reminded him and I just reminded him of it. Whether
he took the advice, I don't know. Something tells me he did and
that's why he's upset. It's actually ironic that I'm even bringing
this question to you because I've uh
it was quite a different situation, but I've been in a drama
where I told somebody not to talk to Aiden uh as a and they did
basically as part of a bit. Well, that's what you get for hanging
around this a hellbent. That's what you get for hanging around
this crew. Well, no. I mean, to be fair, that was like part of
a bit that kind of somewhat backfired. Actually got yelled by
Chad uh about it on a stream. Yeah, you're probably you're always
Hey, listen. When they need a girl to pick on, you'll be it.
I mean, Tommy Tommy did just hit a sensitive spot right there,
cuz that is absolutely Hellbent's role. He He absolutely just
poked a stick into a sensitive spot. When they need a girl to
pick on, it'll be you. Is Hellbent back in spicy chat yet, or
is she still so
not sure? I I just I've seen like Hellb. I've seen the way they
treat I've seen the way they treat you. And I've seen No, he's
actually slightly better at this than you would expect. I expect
him to have like no sensitivity whatsoever or be like a totally
like blind deaf and dumb [__] Uh, no, he he knows
he can he can poke some things. He's not totally dead. Okay.
He's just old. You kind of like do like acting like them, too.
So empathetic. He seems what? Something empathetic.
Tommy seems very empathetic.
I hope he can help uh help me. What's They're going to probably
do something if you pick them. She meant help her. Cherry doesn't
need help. Cherry's fine. Come on. going to do something really
nasty. You're not hanging around like these guys are like I don't
know hairs off of Kiwi farmers, you know. I mean, I just don't
take any of that stuff seriously. If it doesn't bother you, then
fine. I grown ass woman, but you know, don't expect anything
different. Look, you know, a lot of the stuff with Chut and stuff
is common sense. You do this stuff enough, it's like, all right,
you know, yeah, I don't have photograph proof that he colluded
with somebody. I don't have photograph proof um that or or audio
proof or video. Why is Jay talk speaking for her? Because it's
a part of the bit. We're going to pretend that Cherry's like
in trouble and I'm like holding her hostage or something, okay?
Or I'm like forcing her to be here somehow and then she's going
to play into it and pretend that that might be true. But it's
only a bit, okay? That's why I'm leaning into it cuz it's just
a bit. It's a bit. I am perfectly fine.
But if you do this enough, yeah, I don't trust you. I mean, you
have to use common sense eventually.
I'm not here to debate you out of your feelings, but I'm also
not going to agree with them. You don't have to. Fair enough.
I'll warn you. I'll warn you the same way I warned Nick. You
hang around those guys, something's gonna ask you is gonna happen
to you and it's not gonna it's not going to be something you
can blow off. How about that? But I'd say I would just say especially
because this is because this is for most people, right? This
is at least in some way, you know, their business. Mhm. No matter
how serious they are about YouTube. So, I think when you
uh did any of these guys not farm like random locals? I feel
like isn't the whole thing like the fireside chat? Isn't that
entire meme that Nicholas had, isn't that like taking your friends
and putting them out to pasture and farming them on stream? Like
I I don't understand where this whole concept came out that we
like nobody farms each other. Nobody does anything like this.
That seems totally foreign to me. Kind of go out of your way
to tell another creator to not associate or speak to another
creator. So, let let alone a friend. But let's forget about that.
You are you're kind of going out of your way to potentially,
you know, up a business relationship. I think a more ethical
approach. I think if you were to do it like sort of like Blair
did, if you do it like Blair did, um, and he got nothing to back
it up, no examples, no history, I think you'd be absolutely right.
That'd be a really sneaky thing to do. I think if in this situation
where you guys got I mean, he sits there and contacts me yesterday
and tries to come off all nice. I say, "No, it's not enough."
And he goes public with it. So, I mean, he didn't make the voice
note, did he? No, I don't care that he played the voice because
here's what happened. Oh, he didn't. He didn't. He said no. No,
he didn't. He he he he wanted I don't I don't care that he did.
Here's what happened. He sent me the uh the the comical um what
I like to call the HR department letter. It was totally phony.
It was totally inhuman and not the way he would normally talk
to me. So, I knew it was fake. Like, that's not the way he's
ever talked to me. If Aiden's capable of talking like a normal
person,
I've never heard Aiden ever speak like a normal human being in
my entire life. What is this fantasy Tommy's constructed where
Aiden is capable of speaking like a normal human being? He always
talks like this. He always talks in the most overly formal like
nerdy way. That's just how he always is. I've never heard him
outside of that character. Does he exist as a different person
somewhere?
Maybe maybe this is because Tommy knew Aiden when Aiden was like
12. That that's like who Tommy remembers. But Aiden is an adult.
No, Aiden's like that's who Aiden is. He never talked to me in
that manner, right? It was just totally fake. I looked at it.
Um and I was I sent him the audio. I played the audio. You can
hear it over in I played it yesterday. You can play the audio
all the time on the internet and what have you. Um and then I
was going to write then he asked me can I use this and I was
going to write yes sure and I'm like oh god I said shifty I wonder
if he's going to use that and even if he doesn't somebody else
would right. So, I could see how that could be, you know, but
then I was going to So, then I was going to write no and I'm
like, well, then I look like a total phony because then
uh, you know, I will leak on somebody who has no you tell somebody
one thing and they do another, I'll drop that golden rule in
a finger snap. I'm consistent on that. So, I decided not to do
anything
if I didn't if I didn't see anything. Is this the victim, Aiden?
Yes, I've heard this. I've heard this many times.
I didn't respond. I didn't respond to him. I did not I never
gave him permission, right? I didn't respond to him, right? And
I was think if I wake up the next day and I don't see it all
over the place. Uh maybe maybe I was never going to give him
an interview or a bait or anything like that because I I just
I've seen him debate before. Um would you allow them to call
in? Yeah. Uh I don't think he's blocked. He's not blocked. Okay,
that's cool. By the way, just just How is that diff? Hold on.
What's the difference? No, I'd never debate this guy. Yeah, he
could call in my show though, but I'd never debate him. But he
could call in and like give me some criticism.
Never. But he confused on the But he didn't let me finish. That's
probably why you're confused. But he did exactly what he thought
he would do. And he went right to you're dementia, you're drunk,
you're this, you're that, you're the other thing. So I was right.
I was right to blow him off. I was right to warn the other guy.
He came to me pretending he was coming to me as a good faith
person, which he had no intention of bad faith, and he proved
it the next day.
So there you go, Hillben.
So, so just just to be clear, I guess on the timeline of it.
So, when did you I guess sour and Aiden, was this like yesterday?
No, it was a couple months ago. Oh, okay.
And I guess if you if you could answer, when did you I guess
have a conversation with with Nick about your feelings?
None of your business. Fair enough. But I thought I might as
well ask. Um, okay. That is my one topic. Bye. All right. Talk
to you later. Bye-bye. All right. If you do like Okay. Well,
all right. Uh, send me a likes. Yeah. Yeah. Some man came in.
Some man came in next. All right. I gota then it looks like one
of my friends and [__] I'm not so guys heads up.
What's that? I said I guess that was a talk. I guess that was
the talk. I didn't I don't know what the purpose there was, but
All right. Are you here to debate me about Chud Perry? Hello.
Hello. Are you here to debate me about Chud?
Yeah. I just wanted to talk next question. Let's go through these
questions and then we go ahead. We got a whole All right. Um
what topic are you going to pick? You can only take one. Pepsi,
dude. I guess like hypocrisy about you talking about kids
while you're like, "All right." All right. Okay. And are you
going to play by the rules? What? Are you going to play by the
rules? The rules like Yeah. about the topic. I mean, I guess.
Yeah. Stay on the topic. And uh if you're a prick, I'll be a
prick if you're nice. I'll be nice. Fair enough. Yeah. Right.
I mean, Gez. Yeah. You be you going to be starting with me? I'll
throw throw you out right now. Well, no. No. Just I just didn't
I just thought it was like kind of obvious, but yeah, I'll say
yes out loud. I mean, if All right. Go ahead. Go with the rocks.
Go with your argument. Yeah. So, I don't know. just it does kind
of seem like um you're going after like Chud's kids even though
your daughter had to leave your house at 17 cuz you and your
ex-wife are such
First of all, no, she didn't have she didn't leave 17. I got
divorced in 2010. The send the 17-year-old they like left. Can
you explain Can you explain how I went after Herb's kids individually?
I went after his kids. Well, it's just you like brought them
up and it's just like really weird that you do that. I brought
him up. He brought up He brought He didn't really bring up his
kids. I I didn't think it was about the kids. I thought it was
about Chud not being a good father. implying Chud like obviously
was a loser, didn't live with his kids, right? That was the that
was the com. All right, he brought off my wife. Fair play. He
brought up your wife. You bring off your wife. But you did. So
he brought he's one of his kids. So yeah, it was a pretty though.
It's pretty bad. Yeah, but Derek father Derek clicked father.
Jesus. No. See, that's the thing. You can't see this is my problem
with double standard. Uh if I reveal something Hold on a second.
I'll let you talk. I promise. If I reveal something, then that's
game. But he reveals something and it's uh No, it's that's off
that's off base. I'm not accepting that. We're playing by the
same game. Right. But it's not he's not going off. Do you say
the same things about your wife? Whereas you're just deciding
No, but see, no, no, no, no, no. And I've said this before. I
wasn't saying anything about my wife. I was responding to either
a chat or the Keemstar meme that I was mooching off my wife.
When I said that and I'm not done, when I said that, I was making
a joke. He knew it. And he sat there. Oh, Tommy, you're sharing
too much. That phony, bro. So, he pretended I was revealing something
when I was just doing some self-deprecating humor. I dude, I
don't get people like call this phony. Yeah. I don't I don't
know if you understand, but some of this you like play it up
for content. Like you do overreact things. That is like a part
of doing internet content. If you just react the same way you'd
react in real life, like how how much money does Chud make in
donations? If his reaction to Tommy being like, "Oh, I'll just
go back to mooching off my wife." If his reaction is, "Oh, that's
kind of weird that he'd say that." Oh, that's kind of weird that
he'd say that.
Play.
Oh, Tommy talked about my kids. Yeah, it's kind of weird that
he'd say that. Play. But aren't that's how people react in real
life. Go ahead. So you're basically saying Tommy don't get offend
like don't get defensive about this insult. It's clearly like
your job. Well, I'm saying that Chud
Chud thinks that it's like weird that Tommy said it. But he's
not going to go, "Oh, that's weird that Tommy said that." You
know, what the are you doing, Tommy? That's too much information,
right? He's going to do something like that. And Tommy's saying
he's playing it up. And it's like, yeah, of course he's playing
it up. That's his job. His job is to take things that are like
mundane and explain how they're funny or make them funny through
like uh I don't know like hyperbole or humor like joking or just
being loud or whatever. Like he'll he'll do that sometimes. Yeah,
that's that's like his job. Sorry. That's like that's he's it's
weird that he's saying like, "Oh, it's clear overreaction." Like,
yeah, that's his job to overreact to things. That's literally
what Chud's job is. Well,
yes, but you would say that that's his job, so he should be good
at it. And maybe sometimes it's a myth and it comes off more
cringe.
Yeah, sure. I just don't I Yeah, that is possibly true. I just
think Tommy's the only one because Tommy's sensitive to it, right?
I And like I could be sensitive to that. That like I understand
it's about Tommy. If Chud says something like rude about me or
my content, I I would feel like annoyed, but obviously like you
have to go, okay, well, he's on stream. He's making content.
You just have to I don't know. You kind have to just live with
it, right? It's a joke. It's a joke. All right. Well, I mean,
so anything always like Ch's anything that he says is genuine.
You think he's like is going after you completely? I don't know.
I mean, just some people they can read that. I've seen a lot
of people react what you're saying. Be like, "Oh, I see. Yeah,
he's like uh he's okay with like mocking his wife." And so probably
he might I didn't mock my wife. I didn't mock I didn't even mock
myself. If I didn't mock myself, he disingenuously took a self-deprecating
comment and said, "Oh my god, you're revealing too much. That's
bro." And you know what? You don't talk about people that way
and expect to be friends with them. By the way, do you know the
guys that normally talk about me that way? Enemies. Keemstar,
the alt-right metag crowd, and him, and he's like supposedly
my bro. No, I'm having more self-respect now. Yeah, Bridge, right?
Um, is it was this like part of the bridge burning that happened
when Chub was talking about Fortnite or I'll just I'll just remind
you guys the comment Chud made was, "Tommy, you're sharing too
much." That was the comment. Tommy's actually mad at DK for like
the threat, the thumbnail, and the title, right? Chud's comment
was, "Tommy, you're sharing too much." Oh my god, Tommy, bro,
you shine way too much, bro. What are you doing, bro? What are
you doing, bro? [__] you on about. That's That's
what happened. That's what Tommy C is upset about. But Tommy
C is basically saying, uh, this guy is trying to make banter
of this. He's trying to
uh just react to it. I don't like this guy, though. Yeah. I mean,
that's and that's fair. Tommy just wants to make this personal,
right? Yeah. Sure, sure, sure, sure. Well, he I think he's Yeah.
reverse like uh what do you call it? Like just by making it personal
from before as well. Yeah. Yeah. So, it's it's really hard to
take someone who is trying to make it personal and give the insult
like, "Oh, come on. You're you're being too
sure.
Why don't you just Yeah, just go with the punches and like no,
this guy is literally on his whole arc of this is personal."
Yeah, that's fair that once once he's decided to see it that
way that he's not going to go back to seeing it as like just
a joke, right? Like if I Yeah. If I had somebody I really like
if if uh what is it? Tom Fullery was like making some joke about
me and I had to like listen to it and say like, "Oh, is that
a joke or is that personal?" I would just probably assume personal
because I assume that guy doesn't like me. I assume he's like
I assume Yeah. Like I would that's actually a really good example
because I do think that
uh it was never personal to you with the Tom Fery stuff and eventually
like you just tried to like let him breathe and and chill or
just like make it light-hearted and I don't think Tom Faler ever
didn't take it personal. Yeah, that's true. Yeah, that's true.
Was there like I don't remember the Fortnite stuff. All I remember
about the Fortnite stuff is I had a pretty good time. But I did
feel weird about some of the soldier stuff. But I can't He can't
remember it. Neither can I. Cuz it seems like you're saying that
like Chud isn't being, you know, he's like being too harsh for
you the way you would expect the friend to be. So all right,
not too harsh. I'm just straight up straight up phony. I mean,
just the fact that he said that I was revealing something when
I was clearly saying this is my exact words. So if I get a job,
you can't say I'm motion off my wife anymore. And I'm addressing
either a comment or just the meme that that's been around forever.
I mean, Keemstar's accusing me of that. Medicare's accused me
of that. All these people. It's not true. It's also a really
insult to my wife, you know, and I got to tell Why is it an insult
to your wife? Oh, yeah. She's carrying around a loser. So, she's
basically assaulted assaulted her too. And I got that guy's your
friend, you know. So, hey, all fair now, huh? I mean, you know,
he shared his kids. I mean, by the way, I think that's a stupid
rule, by the way. But I think he conveniently used that so he
could justify doing the same thing he's about me doing. You think
it's like a stupid rule. Don't go after kids. Is that a stupid
rule? No, now you're being bad fate. That's not what I said.
Well, don't
it is a stupid uh Perry was Perry was being bad fate there. Perry
knows that's not what he means. go after children. I get it.
I didn't go after his kids. I brought them up. I said, "They're
not around. You're sitting around lonely." Yeah, he attacked
Chud. No, no, no, no. He attacked Chud as a dad. He He wasn't
like doing something dragging Chud's kids into it or something.
He was He was explicitly going after Chud, but I also think it's
weird to go after somebody as a father with like no basis for
it, right? For me personally, that's like a that would be a line.
It's not quite going after somebody's kids, but it's getting
kind of close,
right? Wait, so is it so it's a stupid rule? You're getting circular.
I made I made myself very clear. All right. Look, man. I'm just
not I have a TSL. I apologize. You have what? I'm sorry. I just
want to
No, just cuz I uh English is my first language. Okay, fair enough.
Fair enough. Fair enough. I speak a second language, too. But
if you're out of nowhere, I make a joke about myself. That's
not true. Obviously not true. He says, "Oh my god, Tommy, you're
oversharing." And uses that as an opportunity to go and then
turns around and says, "Oh, well, you brought it up, so that's
game." Oh, no. That's not your friend. I'm sorry. That's not
your buddy. That's not somebody I want. think you I don't think
you can attack someone as a parent and it not be going after
their kids. You absolutely can. No, it's not a distinction without
a difference at all. If I say you're a deadbeat dad, you don't
see your kids and I don't know anything about your kids. I've
never heard I've never seen your kids. I have no nothing about
them. I just know that you don't spend time with your kids. That
is not me going after your kids. And you'd have to be a complete
idiot to think so. Like there's just no What do you mean? How
is that going after somebody's kids? It's not even close.
I don't I more self-respect myself and that's why I stop going
on the show and all that other stuff. Those friends would you
say you do have? How many friends would you say you do have?
Plenty. More than more than I want. More than you want? Yes.
But not in real life. Of course I do. Well, you don't speak German.
How could you have real life friends? I live in a cosmopolitan
area and I speak some German. Oh, I also live in American military
base. It's American neighborhood.
You know, Tommy, I think you're right. I think people are too
harsh on you. I mean, it does seem more experience. I'll feed
you any points. I think you made a point. Take it there. Bye-bye.
Oh, I can't wait to take off mode. Um, I think that guy was German.
You probably listen to Village Friday, guys. That guy was not
German. One second. Lumpy Willy, you got three questions before
we start. Yeah, I Okay, here we go. I heard you wanted to talk
to me. No, no, not at all. Who is this? Is this Lumpy Willie?
Is this the Lumpy Willy collided right now? Yeah, that's what's
occurring. Okay. Okay. Well, here I am. Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Well, no. I'm I'll ask you one final meeting. Uh, yeah, because
you made some All right. All right. Pick pick. If you're gonna
do that, I'm gonna throw you out. Um, pick a single topic.
Well, I mean, okay, the President Sunday stuff. Okay, fair enough.
President Sunday stuff. And do you agree with the play by the
rules? Uh, yeah, sure. Whatever. Uh, okay. Anyway, so I just
want to I just wanted clarification. So, do you think Chud had
an insight into what President Sunday was doing and what? I have
no idea. I said it yesterday. Okay. You have no idea. But that
is your assumption that when he was telling Tom? I think Yeah,
I do. I think that's probably You do realize Yeah, that's just
objectively untrue. Kilo, I messaged Kilo. He eventually told
me the 18th is when they started. They released the videos on
the 20th. Two days before that was when they started script writing.
They didn't know they were getting those texts. They didn't know
basically almost all the stuff they knew. So Sunday would have
known. But Sunday wasn't updating Kilo. Kilo didn't know they're
making a video until like 2 days before they actually put the
video out. And that was a part of their stories right after the
fact. So there's really no reason to be ignorant of this, right?
That they had to rush the video out because they thought they
were racing like bad empanad and a couple other creators.
When those videos came out, Chud was on vacation that whole time,
right? Yeah, I know. But he was he was aware of the video coming
out and he was not aware of the video coming out. What he was
aware of was the stuff that was coming out with Pixie. That's
what was coming out. Why would that make a difference? Why would
that make a difference whether was the video or the stuff that's
coming out Pixie still? I'm in a bad spot. He's telling Tom,
hey, this stuff might go public. So, you know, you should go.
You should distance yourself. And even he cornered him. He cornered
him in that stream after they after they all agreed not. He No,
no, no.
He didn't corner him after. He cornered him after Tom kept saying
things. All Tom had to do is shut up and he was fine. To talk
about Destiny, Nick slipped up and every the opportunist Chud
put Tom against the wall. That sus to me. How did How did Wait,
there's Tommy just doesn't think about what he's saying for two
seconds. In what universe does Nicholas Yuru say something and
Chud grabs Turkey Tom by the throat and says face the wall?
How what what opinion had Tom put out there other than hey, I'm
distancing from Destiny. like way before this. What opinion did
Tom put out there that makes Tom a target? No, it's the opinions
Tom gave on that stream. It was Tom speaking. So are you also
going to go after Auggie for egging Chut on? What? No. Are you
okay? Cuz cuz Auggie in that same stream was literally egging
Chut on to do it when Chud brought I don't think Augie had just
come back. I don't think he knew is egging Chud on just Auggie
saying total destiny death in the background. Let's go TDD. Total
destiny death. Is that is that what egging Chud on was? Was going
on at that point. So no, he knew everything that was going on
at that point. He might I'm pretty sure it was he doesn't stream
like he even used I'm so bro it's so crazy that people are like
oh we had no idea what actually happened there. We didn't know
dude massive drama that was like bo like bubbling and boiling
under the surface. Yeah we had no idea. We didn't know what the
specifics were. We definitely don't talk about this stuff 24/7.
There's no way. There's no way we could have known. He doesn't
that doesn't mean he's not in the community. What are you talking
about? Well I look like this. Look at like the slumpy bully.
I think that's sus as [__] You have every right to
disagree with me and think I'm wrong. But I think it sucks. So
you think it's wrong to press people publicly about their sweeping
for somebody who has I think if you know what's coming I think
if you know what's coming out and then somebody sent me a video
yesterday that he moved away from it. No, I don't think it but
I don't think it was done in good faith. I don't believe that.
I I think Chud like actually helped Tom by being like no no let's
be real like you know that this is the case, right? And then
eventually Tom takes his position. Like then Tom has a position
on the record that yeah it's probably done without consent. And
then Tom doesn't look like he's sweeping anymore. Tom like Tom
looks like he didn't really know and then Chud like basically
went oh well given these facts obviously it was non-consensual
right that's that's how that went I don't believe Chud I mean
he spent the last two days saying that's I feel like the the
way you put that sounds so bad for Tom like the idea that he
needs someone to guide him in like what direction to think no
no I don't think he needs that I think Tom was like in a place
where he'd like decided he wasn't going to talk about it and
then he got into like this weird place where he's like no to
not talk about it I have to not know anything. So he's like,
I don't know anything, but also we have no idea what the consent
situation was. And Chud kind of makes the argument, no, no, no.
We kind of we have a pretty good idea of what it is, right? I
don't think Tom needs somebody. I think Tom, given the facts,
could have known this, but I I think he was just he was like
had a couple different things on his mind. He's trying to like
split the difference. And Tud just was like, "No, no, no. This
is probably what we both think, right?" And then Tom was like, "Yeah,
probably."
I don't think it's like Tom Tom's obviously capable of navigating
drama and coming to like a good conclusion because that's been
like his whole YouTube career. Yeah, I'd never say that he's
like incapable of that. I think I'm not going to say that. I
have no idea if Tom is capable of coming to conclusions on his
own. I actually don't think I have any reason to believe that.
As far as I'm concerned, he's one of those YouTubers where other
people write a script for him. I don't think he started that
way, but I understand that that's probably where a lot of people
see him now. They do some sweeping with the molinist.
uh, I'll see you later, Stallen Sloth. Uh, with the Molita stuff,
I
It's very funny cuz I was like debating on that with, uh, Aiden
at some point and then Nick came in and Nick told me that basically
like the things I'd been told by Chud were not correct about
when they talked and like yeah, I had like a discussion on that
and I I was like, "Okay, I'm not going to fight. I didn't want
to fight with people on that." You know what I'm saying? So,
I that was what I remember. I didn't bother looking into it anymore.
So, we'd have to see. We'd have to go back and watch it. Maybe
this is giving us a reason to go back and watch it now and actually
get what the real timeline was. We'll see. Think about back's
privacy. Enough reason alone never to talk to him again. I never
said that. Well, I mean, I kind of did seem like that, but
that's the problem. That's the problem. I'll let you I'll let
you go back. I promise. Right. That's the problem. It didn't
It seems like that would I clearly state it's not. It still seems
like that. So, that's more dishonesty. Go back to the Sunday
stuff. That's not really I mean, if you're if you keep wording
it in a certain way and people take No, take when I sit there
and say that um Bobax has absolutely nothing to do. Now, I with
the subject I wrote the rules in fairness, by the way. Um, so
I'll give you a chance to break the rules. Um, no. If I specifically
say this has nothing to do with him, this somebody gave your
word. Okay, somebody's giving me a time stamp for I knew I basically
recalled this almost perfectly. This is Auggie egging it on.
This is what people are calling Auggie egging it on. Didn't we
hear this? We heard this yesterday. We did. We did. We did. I
just thought it was funny. I just kind of the main thing like
I don't really know what's going on. I mean, real quick, it's
uh it's not Chud doesn't want to debate it. Chud is just like
giving his opinion and then somebody else says, "Hey, let's debate
it." But I went back. It's pretty obvious. It's pretty. Okay.
Okay. Can we stop this sweeping, please? It's pretty obvious.
Woman on his
It's obvious, dude.
We love Augie here. Okay. He's just scream. He's just yelling
total Destiny death in the background.
Add him to the call. Okay. Bring him in. Show logic. Let's talk
about it. Show logic. Let's talk about it. What do you mean it's
obvious? Okay. Sorry. Tom says, "Let's talk about it." Tom is
like, "Okay, let's talk about it. Let's let's talk about it."
Right? Tom's the one who wants to talk further about it. Chud
gave his opinion. Chud said, "Hey, that's kind of here's my opinion."
Right? And then Tom's like, "No, no, no. Let's actually have
this discussion then. If you Let's just have it. Let's have it
out." Molina commented on it. So, anyway, anyway, so that's where
it goes from. So, like I I don't know that this is Chud's I don't
think you can I think Chud is possibly the least to blame for
this. Okay. Chad, by the way, honestly, I don't know. Okay, I
I just genuinely I don't know what is happening here with Tommy
C except for all of the people that he's acting like he's defending.
They are all getting thrown under the bus all over again. Like,
why is this happening? This is the thing is I Yes. And I I don't
I don't think any of them have to be thrown under the bus. There's
like explanations for this where like nobody is like an evil
person, but Tommy's making it seem like Chud did something evil
and now a bunch of people are going to go reanalyze this. I don't
think this conversation was particularly good for certain people.
Do you feel like Do you feel like he hopes that people won't
actually just rewatch things and they can just set a new narrative?
I don't know what he hopes
what this is. Yeah, I have no idea. He's like actually getting
people to bring things up that are not great. I don't know why.
Yeah, I that's a that's a great point. I'm sure that's part of
the reason why nobody who's like kind of on his side has been
like, "Yeah, Tommy, you're doing a great job. Yeah, Tommy, we're
on your side. I feel like you'd think he's defending all of these
friends, right? You'd think one of them would go, "You're doing
a great job, Tommy." in public, right? Even if it was just like,
"Hey, maybe Tommy has a point here." Something like that, right?
Maybe Tommy, you know, I'm not going to call Jud a snake, but
maybe Tommy's like not totally dumb. No, someone didn't Willy
Mack do that? He replied to one of the videos. Well, he did,
but he did so in a way that probably has plausible deniability
and that he could just be being sarcastic. You know what I mean?
Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
So, it's Yeah, it's uh hard to say. We'll see. We'll see as we
go. I think that's sus. That's And then you constantly have to
make excuses about Bobax's privacy. Then I start to think, "Oh,
you're doing that on purpose. You're deliberately being dishonest.
You're deliberately." But go back. I actually want to go Well,
hold up. I actually I don't believe it to be a joke, but I want
to go to that to the Bob stuff real. The stream looks terrible
for Tom and Nick, especially in hindsight. Well, maybe
I brought it up. Fair enough. Okay.
I'm not going to elaborate again. It's because I broke the whole
rule. I didn't do that. I'm telling the but go ahead. So for
the for the Chud knowing the Bob leaks, right? You do realize
Chud barely found out about that like a month prior to that stream,
right? He didn't know at the same time that you did. What's the
difference? Because you were claiming, oh, he knew about it for
5 months. He No, no, I'm talking. I said I said he this nothing
came out for 6 months and he had no idea what impact this would
have. Yeah. Nothing came out about What if they see Chud the
new Destiny and they're scared of spicy like DG? I I think they
are scared of spicy in a different way than they were scared
of DG. I think they are like transparently scared of spicy chat
which is very funny cuz like realistically spicy chat is like
10 to 20 regulars like and I don't know I don't find them scary.
One of those one of those regulars. Isn't Kenny one of those
regulars? Kenny was one of those are you guys scared of? Uh yeah
that's true. Kenny. I mean, yeah, Kenny is one of the regulars.
Or Kenny literally did. He's the guy who posted pictures of his
feet so somebody would buy him a video game. Yeah. And that is
your boogeyman.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Well, actually, never mind. Never mind.
That level of desperation. Yeah. You should be scared of that.
Okay, I'm seeing it now. Yeah. Like honestly, I would say that
it's not even like spicy chat people who like do most of this.
Like most of the chatters who come and like actually you know
upset these people I don't think they're actually spicy chatters
really right spicy chatters some skitsos who Rita
is Rita the most schizophrenic person there maybe but like Rita's
honestly Rita's just a businessman okay Rita's just getting done
I don't honestly most of those VCs are like for the past like
three months if I join a spicy VC it's like me Aiden and Bug
Swander and maybe Sunday and then like basically almost nobody
else talks. So like I yeah I don't know but I I'm not up in the
morning when there's like a group of people in the morning with
Stylo and
oh Stylo and there's another guy but like Stylo and a couple
other guys who are also a big part of that. I'm more like late
night if I'm chatting there at all. Anyway, I just I don't see
how you could possibly think that they're like evil. Well, sorry.
I No, no, no. Hold on. Okay. You think they're evil? How are
they effective? They're like they're like not very big. They're
not very many people. Well, it's it doesn't have to be that,
right? These are peopleh
I don't want to like specifically talk about these people because
I actually don't see it it myself.
I don't look at the chat and I'm sure they say insane stuff about
me, but it hasn't like leaked out to affect me personally in
any way. Um, but I imagine if you are a content creator and you
know of communities who are online all the time and they like
to go into other spaces and they like to argue with people to
uh to essentially like convince people that you are bad, like
they're going to work overtime to put you down, to criticize
you, to put a negative light over you, to
these all seem like concerning things if you're a content creator
who Yeah. Your reputation is like what is everything for you.
Yeah. I think the scarier thing about spicy is that um like a
lot of those people will actually come argue and they will make
the arguments. Well, I think that's like the scarier thing as
opposed to like DG who will go around and like try to you but
then you talk to one of them and it's just like somebody who's
like like very not intelligent and like not well socialized and
like not at all any kind like you talk to them and it's like
oh this is like just somebody who has nowhere else to be. the
spicy chat people. I feel like it's the different It's not the
same. Ghoul is an antisocial insane person. What? I Ghoul. I
like ghoul. What the? That's up. Don't say that. Ghoul's cool.
What are you talking about? What are you talking about? I don't
like anyway. I don't like calling any chatter cool. Uh, well,
I don't think he chats, so he just types in in spicy. Maybe he
call that a chatter. I don't know. I feel like if you compliment
one chatter, you got to compliment all of them. It's better just
to
say anything good about any of them. I will say though, Deeperama
incredibly funny. Okay. So mad at DDG after they Okay. Very good.
Very good. Uh all right. We we continue. We continue for six
months. But you are everybody kept their mouth shut. I'm pretty
sure Nick told him. Aiden admitted and told him and his both
his replies have been so what? Who cares? And yeah, I didn't
know. Aiden was the only one to tell Chud because Aiden was the
one that brought it up to begin with and showed Chud the picture.
I know that because around that same time around he had the picture.
No, he like showed it to him in a he had the picture. That's
the first picture. Yes, he showed Yeah. All of these people had
this picture. Tommy, me the picture. I know. He showed you the
picture. No, I was told that nobody had the picture except like
Auggie and and the picture. Yeah, Aiden. Aiden had the picture.
I don't see I honestly I don't think the amount of time I knew
doesn't seem to make a difference to me. They told him not to.
That's my whole point. It's not about privacy. I don't give a
[__] about that guy. It has everything to do is he
broke his word. He broke his word. Hold on. Sorry. Give me one
second. Sure. Sure. Go ahead. Well, you can't stop the show.
Hello. I can't do that. Give him a second. I'll give him a second,
but I can't just get dead air. I'm not put this in the queen
here. But that also doesn't really make sense. O, he doesn't
care about Boax or Boax's privacy. Doesn't care what happened
to him. So, he's just like concern trolling because he doesn't
like these people. No, he he's actually it's even worse. He's
like, "Yeah, obviously I don't want his privacy saved. I don't
want any of that." But you told uh you told Nick or you told
Aiden that you wouldn't share it. That's what he's mad about.
The violation of like Aiden's trust, but he said to Aiden he
wouldn't share it. It's like Yeah. Yeah. Like I I wouldn't say
that like sharing it was actually bad because Bo, but you told
Aiden you wouldn't share it. That's that is I think that is concern
trolling. I think accurate to say that's concern. You did bring
this up because now he's choosing to take Aiden's word. Well,
he's choosing to take Aiden's word. That's not just the Oh, sure.
He's also calling Aiden. I told him it was personal and like
now he cares what Aiden says. But you know, but when Aiden asked
him for
shitty and like a total loser couldn't possibly trust you to
like relay it accurately. Okay. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Goofy stuff.
Goofy goofy stuff. Four three. I I'll send a message to let him
know I can't do that like it's not fair. Okay. Sorry. Anyway,
what I was going to say is around that time too right after this
black stuff came out a lot of people the whole reason from my
understanding from what I've heard from a lot of people is that
it wasn't that it was a privacy thing that they didn't want this
to come out. It was mostly the fact that they they nobody wanted
the heat for outing Bob. That's not what I That's what I But
it's irrelevant. It's irrelevant. He didn't keep his word. You're
getting That's It's not irrelevant. It's not irrelevant at all
when all of these people didn't respect this guy's privacy and
somebody comes into that circle of trust and goes, "Oh, this
is really weird how you guys are all violating this guy's privacy
and then pretending to be bros behind the scenes. That's kind
of odd. Ah, you know what? I don't really care. I think that's
totally normal thing. I don't give a about Bobacks. I know Chud
has told repeated that over and over dishonestly. I don't give
a You understand? Do you believe me? Do you not believe me? Even
though I've never thrown any support to blow up ballbacks. Do
you believe me? Love you, Willie. I don't give a [__]
It's about keeping your word. I think you're being bad faith.
But how do you think it's bad faith? I that that means something.
The question is, why was it important to keep this secret? The
the answer should never be, well, you have to keep it secret
because you said you'd keep it secret. You should have a reason
to keep it secret. The reason to keep it secret is because these
people all purported to be Boax's friends, right? That's why
they were keeping it secret. That's why they weren't spreading
it around because they're like, "Hey, we should give this guy
a chance to like not kill himself." Right? That should be what
it is. But that's sort of thrown underwater when the picture
is getting shared around to a whole bunch of people. Okay?
That's all that's like the argument. You shouldn't just say,
"Oh, well, you gave your word you wouldn't talk about this."
It's like, "Oh, what if you thought something up was going on
there?" That can't be. Listen, my wife that I punched in the
face gave me her word that she would never go to the cops and
then she went to the cops and that's up, right? Yeah. something
weird was happening. And I'm not saying Chud did it to be nice.
I'm just saying that like he probably was like, "Oh, you guys
don't care about this guy's privacy. Why you you like pretend,
but you don't really?" That's That's probably how Chud saw it.
Probably.
I mean, Chud could do even worse than that. Ch could be like,
"Uh,
yeah, you guys kept saying it was a secret, but you guys don't
like him." So, I thought it'd be interesting to see if you guys
would white knight for him if I did that. It's interesting to
see that cognitive dissonance of knowing privately you guys dislike
this guy, but publicly you're going to act like what? His savior.
Yeah. Yep. Yeah. It is interesting to think about. Again, another
element of that stream that we probably people wouldn't really
want attention drawn to, but hey, thank God for Tommy C bringing
all of our attention back to this stream that certainly didn't
look great for certain people.
Do you know what? Do you know what bad faith mean? Ba I'm not
doing the definition game. We're not doing red herrings. I don't
I don't you look you're entitled to believe I'm being bad faith.
I eating deep is word. That's what that's how I feel. I'm not
getting in the definition game. I played this game with Queen.
We're not doing it. Whatever. Okay. Okay. Well, you're using
that word entirely wrong. It's a Sunday. Not really. I'm going
back to back to Sunday. Okay. Fair enough. Okay. So, why do you
So, Chud had no idea this was coming out because in that time
period where Chud was on vacation, it was 4 days prior to that
where uh Sunday and Beck had started making their videos. You
do know that, right? Or do you not know that? Well, I'm not I'm
not aware, but I I haven't said I haven't accused him of colluding
with with I do wonder. I do wonder out loud. I have every right
to say that. Yeah, you are making accusations. Oh, yeah. I'm
not saying it's true though. Yeah, I'm saying. Yeah. I wonder
if that doesn't matter. Yes, it does. If I sit down and say yes,
it does because one's saying this happened and the other one's
saying I'm suspicious of this happening. Okay, that is like that
is crazy. No idea. You're broadly implying. You're broadly implying.
I have to. No, no, I am implying it. There's no way. But I have
no idea if it happened or not. I have no idea if it happened
or not. It would not shock me. Is this okay to do if it hurts
somebody's reputation? If it that's that's the question. And
if it is okay to do, then stop complaining about all the people
who said you're a right. You're really mad at all these people
like you're super for calling you a
stop acting like that wasn't something totally fine to do. Who
wouldn't call him a He implied something about Kinetic Kell being
14 and Tommy talking to her. I don't I don't really know much
about these people. I know a lot of people kind of like spread
this sort of rumor sort of maliciously that Tommy C might have
like been talking to 14-year-old girls online. All right. And
implying that is probably not bad if you could just apply things
about people with no evidence that hurt their their uh what do
you call it that hurt their reputation and it's not a problem
at all. Right? That's the argument he's making. I can imply this
about Chud. Yes, it hurts his reputation. No, I don't need proof
and I can just say I suspect this. It's like well you should
probably keep that to yourself. What under what authority? I
guarantee if we could go look at Tommy's background, he would
have like some pseudo review type content where he's calling
a woman who's sort of kind of making a bad accusation like a
total
like this stupid [__] making this accusation. It's
clearly fake. It's so up that she do this to his reputation.
It's like no, she probably believes that she was like or something,
right? But Tommy Tommy's like totally defending that kind of
behavior. Tommy is the person who was raped here, right? And
now he's making a accusation against Chud. That is like the that
is the context of what's happening here, right? He's making an
accusation that could hurt Chub's career, that could hurt his
reputation, but he doesn't really have proof for it. He just
feels that way. That's exactly what most people who write a tweet
longer. That's their exact state of mind. Yes, I feel like this
happened and and I'm going to get my feelings out there. I'm
going to make this accusation even though I don't have like super
solid proof for it. I'm going to say it because it feels good
to say it. And I guarantee you there's videos of him and a bunch
of his buddies all talking women who have done that. And I wonder
under what authority or or how do they feel comfortable doing
that given Tommy C is having his own moment right now where he's
basically trying to twit longer twit longer Chudlo Logic. Just
seems bizarre to me. Anyway, we continue. Okay. It wouldn't shock
you, but if you actually looked into the situation, you would
know that that would be not possible because Chud was not on
the internet when that happened. Chud was away with his kids
on vacation. You have a phone? I talked to Nick the whole time
when I was in Spain when I found out about the Boax leaks. Are
you kidding me? Are you kidding me? What? Jesus Christ. Are you
going to sit there and tell me in 2024 or 2025 that you can't
do this cuz you're on vacation with your kids? By the way, I
was on vacation like his when I found out about Boax. And you're
seriously going to tell me that there's no way he could have
known anything because he was on vacation and today's Stop. Stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. No way. He's calling him a Derek Lick
father and now he's like, "You can't just do this while you're
on vacation with your kids. Stop saying Derek licked. Please.
Please.
I'm sorry. No. I don't That's a word that everybody here knows
what it means." No. Jesus. Okay. Yeah. Just when you're on vacation
with your kids, just keep up with internet gossip. Okay.
It's almost like It's almost like Chud maybe perhaps because
he doesn't live with his kids wants to make vacation moments
matter and last and actually be attentive the whole time he's
there. Yeah. What a dead beat.
It's crazy.
Well, what well what Chud was referencing in that and when he
was warning Tom was also not about the Sunday stuff. That was
prior to the Sunday stuff. The Sunday stuff happened 4 days prior
to that. Chud was talking about what was coming out already.
what already came out on the farms. You do know that, right?
Because it was honestly Now, now I'm totally confused because
what I my
stuff came out a month prior on the farm. That is what Chud Yes.
Kiwi Farms the videos and everything. Yes. Yes. That is why Chud
was warning Tom, hey, this stuff just came out on Kiwi Farms.
The only reason if I put that if you go back to that video, he's
put him on the fence. It's not See, I think that's bad faith
because you're acting like it's a warning. It looks like he's
putting him on defense. Oh, whoops. Well, no. Obviously, Chud
gave him the warning prior to that and then in public cuz they're
still sweeping, but he's making references to the Molina stuff,
which Molina was already I don't buy that. I I don't buy that
at all. I think Judge saw his opportunity once Nick broke the
rule. I mean, you could think something different. You could
disagree with me, but I don't think so. It looked targeted to
me. It looks like you wanted to put him in a bad spot considering
the way he's treated me. Considering the way he treated Willie,
how would you put him in a bad spot if he's already looks like
so he can turn around and call him a sweeper a day later? Let's
let's not be stupid. So, prior to that, okay, so no, no, no.
Because that wasn't your argument. Your whole argument was that
he wanted to he wanted Tom to get backlash from the DG community
for for calling out Destiny and for tipping Destiny off.
No, I didn't. I mean guys like you that were calling No, I don't.
I mean guys like you that were going to call him. DGG would now
why would they turn on him? They were you would be doesn't make
any sense. They were going to turn on him for turning him for
turning on Destiny because that's how Destiny's community is.
If you go against him, they will turn on you. Tom was already
prior to that coming out against Destiny and saying that he wanted
also they would also once the Sunday video got turned on him
for sweeping for Destiny and that's the position I'm saying Chud
put him in which is why when the original when all of the stuff
came out on Wait, what were you saying Spudgun? I recall correctly
Chud was taking a minimal technology vacation because he's an
online content creator want a break from the internet. Are you
talking about for the Are you talking about for when he yelled
at Sunday about messaging him when he's on vacation about some
unhinged DK? I'm looking at you guys on the farms is what Chud
told Tommy Chud told Tom, "Hey, this stuff is most likely gonna
get out eventually because nobody was talking about it because
nobody wanted to out any
about it. I just heard there was stuff out there. I had no idea
that was on the farms." But I
Your argument doesn't make any sense because the video is going
to make it happen. And I'm not saying that DGD is going to throw.
I actually I actually despise that everybody just buys the narrative
that nobody knew what was on KF when it got posted on KF. Like
it's such a stupid narrative that actually people just bought
into for no reason. There's no reason to believe these people
whose entire careers are built on reading Kiwi Farms and making
content and commentary videos on it that they would not have
known precisely what was going on with these posts when they
were happening. It's
insane.
Okay, why do we even Why do we buy this narrative? Why do we
Who purchases this? And for what possible reason? Tommy C is
about to deny Turkey Tom Nuba KF. Well, yeah. I think that's
but that's broadly the narrative that was out there. Oh, well,
we knew that some leaks happened, but we had no idea what was
in them. I'm sorry. Sometimes I feel like I'm so naive. Um
cuz I'm probably This year is when I'm like putting together
that most
I guess what you guys consider commentary videos is just info
coming from KF. KF. Well, and other places, but yeah, KF's a
big one. KF's like a big big big one. Tom's never heard of KF
in his life. Yeah, I it's it's just crazy. And then you add in
the fact that like a lot of these people had like fairly solid
professional ties to Destiny, right? They were going to his house.
They were doing streams with him fairly consistently. Like I
had obviously quite strong tie. Like I knew it was in those leaks
when they came out. I Yeah, obviously. Okay, Kico, shut the up.
I only sound naive when I tell you I'm naive every other time
you ever heard me speak. I sound confident and like I know what
the I'm talking about. You Derek ass. Okay. Anyway, I just I
think that buying that narrative is so silly to me. Anyway, we
we should continue on with this I don't know about it. I just
heard there was stuff out there. I had no idea that was on the
farms. But I
Your argument your your argument doesn't make any sense because
the video is going to make it happen. And I'm not saying that
DGD is going to turn. Let me make this clear. I was not insinuating
that it put Tom in a bad spot for DGG. I'm talking it put uh
OMFG's pro. Most people don't read KF in this sphere where you're
making hundreds of thousands of dollars doing so. You're just
wrong. Yeah. Well, of course, he's not. Yes. That's why they
can make that much money off of because most people are not reading
it. Yes. So, when you say content creators who are making a lot
of money, those are not most people. I know. They are uniquely
part of the class that probably definitely do. We should we shouldn't
take that seriously. It's OMFG. He's pro. He's not capable of
following conversations. He's like, uh, but he didn't technically
say anything wrong.
No, but no, hold on. But why did he say that? Because most people
would not know what you are claiming because it would mean that
they read KF know that these content creators.
Like somebody who argues these people would know.
You're you're making it so hard for me to explain why what he
said makes sense cuz you're like fighting it. Yeah. So what you're
saying is obvious to everybody
would not be it'd be obvious for you and maybe a small portion
of people who actually read Kiwi Farms. Most people don't read
Kiwi Farms. So if they watch the YouTuber, they watch they follow
commentary. They wouldn't actually know that they're just biting
everything from Kiwi Farms cuz most people don't read Kiwi Farms.
That's how you get to successfully like plagiarize all of your
content from it for years without anybody knowing the wiser.
Uh, okay. Yeah, sure. Does that not make sense? Uh, it doesn't
apply to what he said. He's using that as a defense of Tom. That's
that's his point here. That's that's what he's doing. That's
why he did that because he is constantly doing that. But I understand
that that is true broadly. I think you're broadly correct. You
just don't know who that person is. Yeah. Anyway,
um Tom in a bad spot for the Queen's of the world, the um the
the Chuds of the world, the people that would accuse him for
sweeping for DG. I don't know where you got that from. You do
realize everybody was already accusing Tom of sweeping because
Understand and you know what I Exactly. And that's why I think
he put him in that spot. Exactly. People already No, people already
thought that before he even walked confronted on the stream.
That's going to be that's going to have much bigger impact once
the big video comes out. Okay. So when the big video comes out
like a month later, right when how is that a month later like
two weeks that was a new year stream, right? It was a new year
stream. All right. When president Sunday's video come up a month
later like the 15th I think the most Sunday. I mean, this is
really I don't think this really hurts your debate or anything,
but I think that would Let's see.
Three months ago. January 20th. 21 20th. Yeah. But I'm I'm sorry
if you know this is coming out. Hey, listen. I'll give you this
lovely way. You're a lot more fair to me in person than you are.
I'm sorry
is enough for me. You can think I'm not I entirely think that
you are just pushing this but I I don't understand how this video,
which was made 4 days 4 days prior to the release date. What
was it? So the 16th, how does Chud know about this months beforehand
when when
say he knows about this? Beck's on record saying he knows Chud
the video is coming out. Beck is not on record saying I have
no I He does not know if Chud knew the contact.
Wait, wait, wait. But but when is Beckard on the Tommy just doesn't
understand the timeline here. Tommy is like a man outside of
time. Okay. He doesn't understand that Chud could not have possibly
known about this video coming out before this video was conceived
of. So now there's conflict here. Wait, wait, no. No. Because
the only reason President Sunday made the video was because of
something that happened 4 days prior. I forgot. I forgot exactly
what it was, but it was that incident that President Sunny said
it's the pixie tweet saying
something about law school. He got the implication that she had
was going to law school. No, I'm going to make this video because
people because it was already But that's just what he said. He's
starting everybody was already starting to know that that was
Oh, I see. Oh, I see. There's no way no possible way you can
know because there's there's literally absolutely no way. Okay.
Oh, I will. I still like to see their communications.
I would love to see their communications. I would because I I
I could I could see something going on there. Here's another
thing. It doesn't change the fact that I think he put him in
a bad spot. I still think he's put in a bad spot for the people
be accusing him of sweeping for Destiny. Yes, I do. You don't
have to disagree. You could totally disagree with me, but I still
think he's put in a bad spot. Now, I'm assuming what you're telling
me is true. So, this is Tommy saying that basically
I'm trying to think
how could I there's like a metaphor that would capture this,
but it's it's Tom who unfortunately put himself in a bad spot,
right? Tom was saying things that Tom couldn't defend and Chud
basically didn't want to like stomach that for whatever reason.
You could say I I understand Tommy's saying, "Oh, well, Chud's
just bad faith. He's looking to step over Tom." Like, he's trying
to embarrass Turkey Tom because that'll put a notch in his belt,
right? But I I think Chud just doesn't think Destiny's a good
person. Doesn't like people sweeping for Destiny in general.
Had to deal with that when he had a split from Destiny, right?
Where people would say, "No, Destiny is not really doing anything
crazy, right? He's had to deal with like this. I feel like he
just had enough and was just like gonna say, "No, no, no. That's
obviously not true. Here's what's obviously true." And Tom was
the person who was saying the things that Tre disagreed with
and and Tom was trying to stand up business and say, "Let's talk
about it." Unfortunately, Tom sort of kind of himself. Okay,
it happens. But I told Beck's on the record saying he knew the
video would come out. Now, did he know back then? No, I will
concede on that video. Is that fair? If he I'll take your word
for it. He knew the video would come out. But I still think I
No knew the video was coming out, but I could knew also 4 days
prior to that because they told both made their videos at the
exact same time. He said Chud knew it was coming out and I don't
know the timeline in fairness to he said Chud knew about it now.
He did not he he said I don't know if he knew the context of
it. I knew the context of it which is why I called Nick. So yeah,
I I got to be honest with you. I mean Oh, so Tommy basically
just made some up and told Nick, "Hey, Chud knew that video was
coming out. Chud knew you guys were going to look really bad
if he pressed you there." Is that what was happening here? Tom
saying or sorry yeah Tommy is saying that hey I called Nick and
let him know that like Chad actually knew that video was coming
out and Chud is actually trying to make you guys look bad. I
mean you're saying this stuff I this is the first time I'm hearing
farms. You're saying he knows all stuff. They know the title
waves comment. I mean Becca told me like one of the reasons he
contacted Nick is because he knew how your side of the committee
would react to it. There's it's not really really hard to to
believe
well or judge community where the people that call the NTGS call
whatever you want. I mean we can get we don't have to get split
hairs here over the committee. Let's make it really simple really
practical. the people that would be calling Tom a sweeper that
his enemies giving them ammo his How is that how is saying oh
you're a sweeper I feel like you're putting way too much emphasis
on that word because it's really not it's really not that big
of a deal obviously you think so you think so I don't I don't
agree to it agree to it and then he cuts it on Tom and then Tom
never shows up again I guess we both have dementia
I I don't I just I'm just at a loss for words I'm going be like
I'm going to be real this is just crazy I'm pretty sure Tom just
Yeah Tom just didn't Tom just didn't enjoy streaming because
he just didn't have the time for it I'm pretty Sure. He came
out and said that. He came out and said he just didn't have time
to share. I came out. I don't know. I'm sure he's going to come
out. I'll come out because I think Jud logic is a complete snake.
These he would have got what I got. Are you kidding me? He's
not an idiot.
I mean, come on. Look what happened days. Let's pretend that
didn't happen. If anybody does that, this is what happens. You
think I didn't know what was going to happen? I'm I'm sorry.
I'm just I'm just You're lost words for what? What? For for what?
Like I just don't understand. I just don't understand what you're
trying to say. I just Are you gaslighting me? Because he wouldn't
come out. He would Tom is not going to come out and throw Chad
on the bus. It's not good money. It's not good business. Do you
understand that? Do you understand what I just said? Okay. So,
if he's not going to throw Tom, if he's not going to throw Tread
under the bus, why why don't you throw Destiny under the bus?
I'm pretty sure he did. I mean, I just said video that he said
he was moving away from him and I think when he interviewed,
but that was prior to him quitting. That was prior to him putting
the thing even
going to move away, but they wanted to see how the whole thing
got settled first. And that's something President Sunday accused
them of that they were going to No, he was he was already No.
Okay. In that clip, he literally says he wants to distance himself
away from Destiny. Period. Yeah, he says. No, he doesn't. He
says DG in that clip, not Destiny. He is Destiny. If you could
say that whole community, are you nuts? Are you nuts? There's
a community. There's an individual. There's my community and
there's the individual. You could off my community off me. I
mean, but the difference is DGG is That's a hilarious position
to have for somebody who's blaming Chud Logic for purely his
community's actions, right? Like there is essentially zero actions
from Chud that are going after any of these people and he's he's
basically blaming Chud for all of it. So now he's like, "Wait,
no, no, we should make a differentiation between Destiny and
DG.
Uh, particularly funny because the way those two communities
operate, specifically Spicy versus Chud and then DG versus Destiny.
DG is not doing a bunch of [__] Destiny doesn't want
them to do. That's I'm sorry. That is a very very very simpy
community that is like borderline culty. Okay, I think Spicy
Chat kind of with Chud. They with everybody. Okay, they don't
not with Chud. They with Chud a lot in the same ways. The Gawk
jokes didn't come from like an anti-chud logic community. Okay.
That's not where those jokes come from. Sorry, what did you say,
Cherry? I missed that. What? You were agreeing on the community
split. Are you good? I Sorry, I missed what you said there. You
were saying like uh-huh or something on the community split between
DG and Destiny or like Did I just make a noise?
Yeah, I could have sworn you like trying Oh, never mind. I thought
I thought you were trying to like make a point as well. My bad.
I'm hearing things. That's my bad. You were just talking for
like two minutes and then decided What did you say, Cherry? Like
and I hadn't said anything. Okay, but I am literally hearing
things. It's my bad. Destiny. Everybody else is an orbiter of
Destiny by saying I want to leave BG. That is essentially you
saying I want to get away from Destiny. No, that's not true at
all because that is all at
you're being dishonest because you can say hey listen Destiny
I like you but your community sucks. Come on. Let's be real here.
You can totally say that. Let's not pretend like you can still
have a relationship with Destiny. You still have a relationship
with the community without Destiny. I mean, let's let you say
it once and the same. And it was tacid, by the way. He tiltedly
moved away. He was in an uncomfortable bad situation for him
that I believe Chud made a lot more difficult and more uncomfortable.
And yes, I'm willing to bet on purpose. So, do you have do you
have any proof to back that up? Why Chud was somebody who was
around Destiny and moved away from Destiny? Why would Chud intentionally
make it worse for people?
That's actually crazy. I I have no idea why you would think that.
Tried to explicitly like tried to I think uh I don't want to
leak again, but try to actually message me when I was like kind
of exiting that community and was like explicitly like, "Hey,
um if you need like a raid or something or if stuff's like not
going well, like just chat with me and I can help you out while
you're like exiting that community." Like he explicitly said
that to me. So I don't understand why you try to go after Tom
and make it hard for Tom to leave. Well, weren't those people
like getting closer and closer to Destiny? They were making more
content with him. They were looking forward to more like what
was it that they were doing? The election stream was when it
was I guess it was mid November. They were going to do this whole
thing where
they Oh, they're going to get like segments. They were going
to do segments. Actually, I got a podcast too.
What's that? Sorry. He like had a bunch of commentary people
to what was it like a study or something? see how much they knew
and how much he could. He was trying to keep a Jan 6th, right?
He was trying to give them like a Jan 6 walkthrough. It's like
live grooming sessions. Oh, wait. I also forgot. Where's that
January 6th documentary? What the happened to that thing? We
get that by 2028. Can we prevent a Can we prevent a third Trump
term with this January 6th documentary? Are we going to make
it? We'll see. Right before the next election.
Could we get it by put out the signal for an editor? 2027, guys.
Okay. So I I don't think anything I don't know anything. I'm
not sussing anything whatsoever. But I would say that you're
not tread thinking, "Oh, I'm starting to distance and here's
this whole community I have that's like doing its own thing."
That's not really the case anymore. When over the last year that
whole community has been like pulled closer and closer to this
dude on his whole I'm going to read and not do any drama arc.
like how does he also simultaneously become closer and pull in
more community
uh commentary people? I get what you're saying. Are you you're
saying that that's probably like it's because of the business
opportunity, right, of like being around him around him, but
I would I don't know what it is, but I would say if I was Chud,
I probably feel like the distance that I thought that I got feels
like it's um pulling in the opposite direction. Yeah. Yeah. Like
I probably need
Yeah. Like if these people are starting to get brainwashed, I
probably need to jump ship again or something.
Yeah, if I was Chad. I don't know what Chad is actually thinking.
And the Well, the other thing is is um I guess for me there's
no reason to
not help me in the same way that like probably the argument I
guess Tommy or somebody else who's conspiratorally minded is
they they think well Chud could peel a bunch of audience off
of Tom, right? But Chud probably doesn't want like former DVers
anyway. like he's kind of shown like an antipathy for that. So
like going after Tom's audience, maybe there could actually be
value there. Like I I I'm sure that's how they would look at
it, right? Like that could be a reason why he'd go after Tom
and not after like me or something.
So uh maybe maybe that Tom that in private. Do you have proof
yourself that I wouldn't say it if I did. Okay. So you're just
making So you're just like insane assumptions. No, it's No, I
don't think it's pretty insane. I don't think it's You think
it's insane. You're entitled to think that. Well, if you don't
if you don't have any if you don't have proof without common
sense, you know, the way he treats me, the way he treats Willie,
um that stunt, the Boax thing, put that all together. His history,
I'm finding out he fights with absolutely every one of his allies
going all the way back to Bread Tube. Is that true? I just heard
that today. I don't know. Can you back me up on that? He fights
with his allies. Yeah. Does he get into it with all his friends?
I'm asking you. This is not me accusing. I mean, he rifts. I
I No, no, no, no, no. Fallouts, all his allies. Is that true?
Uh I know. The only one I know about Star. I don't The only one
I know about is Star, but does it go all the way back to Bread
Tube? Chloic's Fallout was Stardust. Legendary. Okay, we've all
heard of it. I know when that happened. That all happened on
the stream with um No, nobody's ever heard of that. Nobody knows
what the you're talking about. Oh, okay. Yeah. I What the Oh,
the infamous Stardust Chudlo Logic Fallout. Okay. I maybe I maybe
know about Demon Mama cuz Demon Mama was trying to press him
on the on the little boy logs, right? I think I think Demon Mom
was somebody trying to cancel him over that, but uh that would
be the only one I'd know about. I don't know about other allies
that he sort of picked off unless you want to count Will and
his channel. Oh my god, there was a stream from uh it might have
been it might have been
it was some TwitchCon. There was a stream where like Wicked Supreme
and Chud were sitting on a stream and talking and Will and his
channel came up and like was talking to them and Wicked Supreme
and Chud both basically were like the is wrong with you. Get
the out of here. Like not joking. No, no, no, no, no. I know
that Supreme that was Supreme was the Chud just kind of sat there
and like It was Supreme, wasn't it? It was Supreme. I think I've
asked Supreme about it. It was like one of the funniest things
I've ever seen cuz I didn't know who Bill was. I just thought
he was like a fan. He like walked up. He's like, "Hey guys, how's
it going?" And Supreme like looks at him and he's like, "We're
just having a private conversation. Do you need something?" And
he's like, "Uh, I don't know." And he like pulled the lid off
of his beer bottle and like throws it over his shoulder or something.
And Share's like, "The are you doing? We're like at somebody's
place. Why would you just throw that on the ground? Get the out
of
It was up. I I like I felt so bad for this re this [__]
I'd never seen before. This poor guy, this weird chatter that
just showed up. And Supreme's like, "Get the out of here. Nobody
wants to talk to you." And he was like, "Haha, see you later,
guys." Oh, is it Chud who yelled at Will? Yeah. Okay, then it
was Chud who yelled at Will. Listen, it's it was funny. It was
very funny. Quinn just went over it. Oh, maybe he's got a time
stamp for it. Dude, I remember that. I brought that up supreme.
That like sticks out in my head as a thing that happened. It's
very funny. That's such an old clip. Why was Clemen going over
it? I don't know. He might think of it as fondly as I do. Somebody
just sent me this to say this is what they were doing at that
time. Can Destiny host another seminar for drama YouTubers where
he explains the tenant media stuff to normies? I am way too lazy
to research this myself, but it seems funny. I like the concept
of Destiny sitting me and Tom down for six hours and giving us
a college lecture every few months so I am less useless when
discussing discussing ah is this like raising her hand and being
like yes tell me the propaganda sir a little bit but I mean I
guess propaganda I mean the tenant media stuff's pretty
although to be a yeah I don't think Destiny has a very um unbiased
look at the tenant media stuff either okay okay that's all I
can really say there but we I don't want I just put that I just
generally think that if you are not so interested in politics
that you don't want to find out your opinion for yourself
don't make content about politics. Yeah, it's pretty easy. Yeah,
I think so. Instead of that's true that it's not it's not him
saying I want the facts, it's him saying tell me the correct
opinion to have. You have no idea what opinion to have. You have
no idea what the somebody is feeding you. Yeah. Yeah. It's not
like it's not like interal drama. It's not like conflict. It's
not like some allegations where most people they'll have some
sort of shame for covering for like a
like you don't mind. With politics, I feel like
don't trust it. The most shameless people in politics. Uh sometimes
you get things like the Matt Gates thing and then it can be a
and a politician at the same time and they're still shameless
about defending him. Uh I I know about one. I don't know. I don't
really know the shore. All right. I know. I don't know who I
know. Fair fair. Well, Mr. Girl, [__] him. I don't
blame him on that one. But I'm sorry. He's got his. And by the
way, you know, fair enough on Mr. Girl. Mr. Girl, actually, you're
not getting You called me a [__] off. Ban him for
life. So, you're not getting your opportunity
in past. You think I gave that was uh that was Riy apparently.
Apparently Riyle called him a time to talk. Yeah, I guess so.
I just think you're making crazy assumptions about All right,
fair enough. We'll have to read this right. All right. Sorry,
I didn't get the unwanted. What's the other side of the tenant
media stuff? Uh Lauren Southern is there. Oh, no. Omfg. He's
pro. You're totally wrong. You're like disgustingly sadly wrong.
Uh when I covered Lauren's whole thing, her Canadian Parliament
thing, Destiny was DMing me explaining exactly how she wasn't
as culpable as the other tenant media people. Like 100%. So you're
actually just totally wrong. Completely incorrect, but it's fine.
Fine, man. See it, man. Yep. Nobody had a lot of time. I'm not
taking that from guy. That guy is a I mean you said about Kell
was out of line, so [__] Oh, damn. All right. Well,
I got your last debate then. Oh, you're debating. Are we debating?
Are we debating? Because I gota Yeah. Yeah. Beans on toast people
or not. Go through go through the uh let's go through the list.
I got because we're friendly. So, I mean, I'm gonna just gonna
do some British people. Bad guys. Um just to go through the thing.
Um we do have uh we have I would say relationship, but we have
we're friendly. So, full transparent. If you if you think he's
going to sweep for me or go soft on me, um I don't know what
he's going to say, but um we do have background. Okay. Do you
want to do Amy on Chad? Uh yeah. Okay.
Is that even that beans on toast? Hold on. The the other side
of the coin is the fact that if you are so oblivious that you
do not know that you're getting money from Russia, that you are
a puppet for Russian propaganda, you have no business informing
anybody on how to have like common sense or critical analyzing
skills for what's going on in the world. Yeah. You need to like
see yourself out of the conversation.
And these people won't do any of that. They'll fain ignorance
and then also tell you that they're the only ones who could tell
you the truth about what's going on and who's who's passing money
behind whose hands and actually there's no gold in the reserves
like no all these people or they're trying to replace all the
whites if they're going to use a literal thing with Lauren Southern.
Yeah, replace all the whites while they literally every tan guy
and every black girl that crosses their path. Wow. Oh, but we
have to save the white race. Save the white. you come inside
other guys. Why do you hate every every white
every white who turns his camera on to say that they have to
preserve the white race is dumping all of his loads in another
guy's acts. Can you just respect Elijah Schaefer and his his
platform for two seconds? What the [__] I don't listen
to any of these. Yeah, sure. Sure, sure. Sure, sure, sure.
Very real. A second. Thank you for the five gifted. Let's go,
guys. We are four more gifts away and or $20 away from another
hour on the stream. We still have Warren Smith on whatever we
haven't covered. We still have all of the Israel Palestine stuff
that I'm pretty sure I'm covering today. Okay, assuming we get
any amount of time going. All right, I need more time. So, I
need you guys to dig deep into your hearts, into your wallets,
and pony up. Okay, exclamation point. Donate in the chat. That's
how you donate money. Okay, you can give subs. You can sub on
Twitch. Twitch.tv/jc TV/JCLK with an underscore. You can throw
your primers my way, too. Okay. twitch.tv/jlk
with an underscore. Can I ask Twitch in the chat? Will that give
me a thing? It will not. So, I'll just throw the link in there
myself. I'll do it myself. Okay. Give subs. Donate money. Buy
TTS. Let's Let's go. I need more time. Money, money, money. Keep
the stream going. Keep the stream going forever. We'll do this
forever.
Subscribe. Donate a sub. Donate a couple dollars. R. Kelly is
in not in prison. He's in the hospital right now. He fainted.
He passed out.
If you donate to us, we're going to make sure absolutely nothing.
I actually have no affiliation with R. Kelly in jail. Him or
his legal team.
Oh jeez. If it makes you feel like you're helping, you should.
Yeah, for sure. Um, overt dummy, thank you for the five gifted
Soapbox, thank you for two gifted. Everybody doing their their
part, everybody, you know, taking up arms trying to add more
hour another but more hours onto the stream. Okay, we we just
added an hour. I just added it now. We are six subs and or $30
away from another hour on the stream. We've got content for days
and days and days. So, as much time as you guys want to add.
Okay. Well, although I actually should probably make this more.
Can I finish my AR Kelly update? I'm so sorry. Finish your Arch
Kelly update. I'm so sorry I cut you off. Go, go, go. Um, yeah.
So, it's not from
uh R. Kelly's lawyers.
I don't know if these are like confirmed sources or confirmed
what happened yet. Uh, so we'll wait for more information, but
so far the rumor is that he's been trying to get his sentence
uh moved over to
confinement at home. Um, because he claims that three prison
three times prison guards have tried to kill him. Um, he's been
put in solitary confinement because of this. and
uh in solitary confinement. He says all he's been taking is his
anxiety meds and something happened and he's been like faint
and woozy for the past couple days and he just passed out like
I think today or yesterday and so now he's in the hospital and
I think his lawyers are claiming that somebody tried to kill
him in solitary and they let him be in the hospital for like
just a few moments and then put his ass right back into solitary.
They don't trust him. They they don't trust him. I don't think
they're going to let him go home. very possible that um it could
be like a stunt. He could be like holding his medication and
then taking a bunch of it so that he faints to try to cause like
a commotion or whatever and either get himself out of solitary
or get him himself give enough cause or enough reason to feel
like they should just uh imprison him in his home. Yeah. I wonder
I wonder how you could even figure that out cuz it was an overdose
on medication he was prescribed, right? So, it could easily be
that he was like cheeking the pills and just waiting to overdose
himself and now he's like, "Oh, they're trying to get me in here.
Oh, no."
And you would think, right, from because we watched his trapped
in the closet series, you would think that he's probably fine
with solitary confinement. Kind of like a closet. Um, but maybe
it is a triggering experience to be back in that closet.
Now, I'm locked in the closet. The closet. We literally never
finished that ever.
Remember when the [__] came out the the kitchen sink
cabinet? I do remember that. Yes, that was a long time ago. Oh,
someone needs to put all those videos together. We had such a
hard time finding them. If they could all be put together in
one shot.
Oh, that's like cinematic gold. That must be That must be more
than a year ago, actually. Unironically. Yeah, that was like
April of last year or something. Yeah, crazy. Maybe even February.
Jeez. All right, we uh we continue on with the Tommy C stuff.
I think this is basically done, though. So, yeah, it probably
be Warren Smith. I think Sophia just sent me some time stamps
on Warren Smith. So maybe some cool stuff there. We'll see. Toesy
people classes crazy. All right. So you're jumping around. So
you don't you don't want that. So what do you want? What do you
No, listen. I I think that this is I think you just ended this.
This is great. I think this is fantastic. I just never I just
[__] I got news for you. I didn't [__]
I was actually I got to give Lumpy Willie a little bit of credit.
I thought he was completely insane with his cap text and um his
his like uh not very generous um um delay text over to interact.
Come on, Tommy. I was just kidding around.
I was just kidding around. If it makes you says this donation
is not him. He wanted me to keep going with the content just
to say this donation is not him. He would never say this. This
is up. Okay. All right. I think that's I think that's it. I don't
think there's anything else cool going on with the Tommy C stuff.
I am going over to this I'm from Los Angeles and Wait, that's
a woman. Hold on. What? I Oh, guest intros. Wait, do we not get
a Warren intro first before the other guests? We wait all the
way for them to go around and then we get to Warren Men last.
Excuse me. What? Okay, I guess so. And I'm 28 years old. I don't
Are we watch I don't think I'm watching all of them. I think
I'm watching Warren and then some time stamps for around Warren.
This This would be We're close. Rock and roll. Welcome everybody.
We're going to go around the table once more. Wait, what? What?
What? Here we go. And uh gotcha
pop. We'll do champagne.
What did I miss?
Right. What about you? Warren Smith. 38
Dude, this guy's What the [__] He's 38. He's 38 years
old.
What?
How
in the world? Blood. Adrenochrome.
Yeah, this is some adren. It's my birthday. Hold on. Let me I
gota play something over that. All right, guys. It's It's Warren's
birthday. You got You guys got to show him a little bit of Bro,
that is Peter Pan looking at us. That is crazy energy to bring.
I turned 38. Looking directly at the floor. I turned 38 today.
Actually, it's my birthday.
Ah,
I think this is some kind of riz. Is this like a kind of riz
where you pretend to be like so helpless that one of these women
just wants to like destroy your innocence? Is that what he's
going for here?
I don't know. Why does it look like he's about to sparkle in
the sunlight?
Love in the chat. Maybe we'll get him. We can do
birthday. Some sort of birthday pop. We'll do champagne. Maybe
a cake. This is why, guys. This is why you should be an incel.
Okay. Not touching a woman for 38 years. You don't even age.
This guy looks 25 years old, 22 years old. All right.
You just don't. You just stay away from women. And this is what
happens. Yeah. What happens is you end up having the posture
like you don't women. Never give women your vitality. Okay. As
John Zurka would say, your seed, your seed is your vitality.
Do not give it away to women. Okay? And you remain young forever
like Warren here. Let's go. Also, you might have some weird posture
issues. Not great. Not
What do you like? Sure, man. We're going to All right. We're
going to do it all. We're going to do it all. Happy birthday.
Thank you. Uh, so you just turned 38, right? Just turned 38.
And, uh, where you from? I'm from Massachusetts.
All right. Boston. Just outside Boston. Just outside Boston.
And, uh, education. Master's degree. Uh, what, uh, what university?
And, uh, what? Emerson College. Video field production. You said
uh, film production. Video field production. Okay. Gotcha. Gotcha.
And what's your current occupation? I do content creation now
full-time on YouTube. All right. Rock and roll.
And uh your the name of your channel is just Warren Smith Secret
Scholars Society. Okay. And uh what can you explain that? What
is the Secret Scholars Society? What's the meaning? Came from
my thesis project. It's kind of a long story. It's during World
War II. The role that Harvard played in smuggling over
technology from England during Blitz. So kind of inspired the
name. Got it. Rock and roll. Well, welcome everybody. We're going to
go around the walk and wall guys. Walk and roll. table once more.
Why not? Walk and walk. Shall we? I don't. Walk and walk. It
What is your current relationship status? If you're single, how
long have you been single? And what's the longest? Okay.
I don't know how we're going to go through this cuz it is a seven
and a half hour episode. I do not want to watch the whole thing.
Should we go just do we should we just go to a couple of these
things? I have timestamps. Sophia sent me time stamps for when
she figured he was talking. What was he app? I'll just try to
do the to Sophia time stamps and then go back to wherever he's
talking from. See if we can go back and reverse engineer.
I'm single. I've been single for like two weeks. My longest relation.
Wait,
he's been Is he going to say how long he's been single for or
is he going to say he's in a relationship? What do we think?
I think he's single. I don't know. He's got like a burgeoning
YouTube career, a YouTube like channel and stuff. Maybe he's
uh maybe he's getting it in now. Maybe Ank's getting it in. Relationship
was almost two
All right. Uh Warren, what about you?
I am engaged off the market, settled. Congrats. Congrats.
As the old man here, I'm happy to speak honestly although about
my experiences if I can provide him male perspective. Sure. Uh
how long have you been uh dating your current? Two years. Two
years. Gotcha. And how long have you guys been engaged? We were
talking about it for a while. That's one of the conversations
we can have around. Huh?
What? What do you mean? You were dating for 2 years and you were
talking about getting engaged for a while. What the That sounds
normal. What do you mean? What the Is that normal? I Yeah. You
start talking about getting married after like a year or two?
Yeah. Okay. That sound really fast.
Okay. I think that's normal around whether
old people get engaged faster. I think lots of people get engaged
after like a year or two. The idea that you'd be like uh dating
for like 5 years, I think that's not very normal. Not to get
the government involved in marriage. I think there's an interesting
sure dialogue there that I that's one of the things that's been
holding me up. It's like how do we that's got to be a massive
red flag for women, right? Listen, I'm not against getting married.
I just don't think the government should have a role. Couldn't
we just get the rings and like not actually get officially married?
Do we need to get the government involved? Yeah. Why? You know,
so you're thinking of just getting a tax exemptions. Obviously,
that's why you get to the government. That's why I thought Okay.
Yeah. But that's also what I thought was so bizarre about um
a bar bizarre thing that I found out about David Pacman cuz he
does the whole thing. He doesn't feel like he should have to
put down that he's married. So, it's technically just has a girlfriend
but life partner but they have a kid together. And I'm like,
"Oh, and you and Cali and she doesn't need that paper. That's
interesting." Oh, what is there something about Cali laws that
would make you want to be officially married? Like, it's a really
expensive place to live. Oh, I see what you're saying. Yeah,
I'm pretty sure under almost all laws though, when they're like
that long together, you're like common law at that point almost
everywhere. Like, it it probably doesn't. Tell that to XQC and
Adept. She's still trying to get her back. Yeah, but Adept Yes,
they were married. That's what I heard. It's okay. Hey, we're
having a ceremony here. You know what, XC? Cut adept off a $100
million check right now. Okay,
let's go. Pay her. She earned it. Okay. And give her another
car. She packed on a lot of weight to keep you warm at night
during CO. Okay. She did that for you, XQC. She gave you her
best years. Cut her a check. At least 10 mil. Do it. Do it or
you a [__] Yeah, but not going to the courthouse
and getting a marriage license and all that. No, it's the most
legally significant thing you can do except for dying. You You're
entering a massive contract that I don't think most people understand
the impacts of and these past experience I'm referring to. I
came close once before younger and I learned a lot from that
So there are lessons to be learned and that goes to prenups and
things that I have an interesting perspective on that. It all
ties into I guess the legality conversation. Dude, this guy is
so authentic. It's so funny. This is going to be so good watching
the This is like the opposite of like Andrew Wilson, almost everybody
else they bring on the show who like outgoing. They'll carry
conversation the whole time. He's just kind of sitting there
with his arms crossed. She's like, "Yeah, I got an interest in
He is
He is the one who's going to trauma dump at the table." Uh you
I could see it. Sure. But And uh you said you've been with your
current uh partner for 2 years. Yes. Uh what's the longest relationship
you've ever had? Oh man, I don't I don't know. Don't know. There's
been too many. There's just been too many. Um I'm going to try
and be I don't This is a new environment. I think this is a number
that basically everybody knows in their head all the time, right?
Yeah. He's such a liar. I think pretty much everybody just knows
this number. Whatever the longest relationship was or they they
know like what Yeah, you just know this. I'm sorry. Sure. Yeah.
I don't usually do. Let's just say two years is the longest.
I'm going to I usually don't date. That's okay. Yeah. Speak honestly.
Best I can still. So I don't know like five years maybe. I
sounds good. We have a chat coming in here from Desert Joe. Desert
Joe donated $200. Thank you, man. Appreciate it. Been a fan of
Warren for a few years before he got cancelled. Love his takes
on various topics based. Glad to see him live and expanding his
reach. Happy birthday, Warren.
Thank you. That's like his mom or his dad. That's like a parent.
That's a parent dono right there. Desert Joe, thanks for the
message, man. Appreciate it. He says you got uh cancelled I guess.
What what's is that true? Is what's the story there? I guess
in a way um I was teaching
at a high school and a video of me about after I met that girl
actually which is interesting. I
Yes. The one I'm settled with. Correct. Listen guys, I was teaching
at a high school and you know after I you know I made a video
well you know after I met that girl. I met that girl at the high
school. You met the girl? Okay.
About a month later, a video of me teaching. There's no way his
girlfriend's 18. There's no way his girlfriend attended that
high school. Stop. That's a joke. That can't possibly be true.
Don't make things up. I had uploaded to my teaching portfolio
on YouTube and Elon Musk tweeted it out on X and it went kind
of went crazy and literally changed my life like overnight in
this very strange way. And I saw this door open. I was like,
"This is once in a-lifetime opportunity. I'm making very little
money as a teacher. My whole life I was describing how my whole
background is wanting to connect with an audience through video.
Suddenly I had that opportunity. So I was like I'm just going
to run as far as I can. See how far I can get and that the school
didn't like that which I in certain ways I can understand. They
viewed it as a liability. Fired me that okay am I do I don't
do this do I? I don't talk into the mic for a little bit and
then I go
they saw it as a real uh they saw it as a possible conflict and
I just saw it as a real opportunity. Am I you guys are all going
to hear it for the rest of this thing. You know I would have
complained by now if you do that that which I in certain ways
I can understand they viewed it as a liability. Fired. You hear
it? Oh, what's up? How's it going? He's a vampire. He's sucking
the souls out of the people around him. Okay. The the young and
the living. Yeah, he's very young. Yep. Listen,
my spies have told me that you were My ears are burning, okay?
About a certain incident involving when you when you totally
on Will and ruined his It wasn't that It wasn't like actually
destroyed his will to live completely. It was It He probably
felt like that. It was probably the worst like 10 15 seconds
of maybe that year for him. I don't know. But no, I didn't tell
him to get the out of here. It wasn't that aggressive. Like,
okay, he had been trying to have this. I'm just going to tell
you, I may or may not have the clip loaded up right now. So,
I'd be very careful. Do you want to Do you want to make a statement
on what it was like? You can watch it. I do. Yes. Because you
know what? If I if I try to dress it up after the fact, then
you'll just it'll just look like I'm dressing it up after the
fact. Okay. I'm going to stake my position early. Um, so like
Chud had this amazing awesome place, okay? And we had like a
bunch of people over and we were doing this stream on this patio
and uh I think Will had been sitting with us for like 20 to maybe
40 minutes. He'd been with us for a little while. I wanted to
get a rotation of people like onto the stream and so I was like
already kind of waiting to be like, "Hey, well, go grab someone
from downstairs, you know, let's let's get people on off the
stream." And he did something with a bottle cap. He like flicked
it or something like that and it like went bouncing on the thing
and Ch was like, "What the [__] are you doing?" And
then I like I could I wasn't I should have been more diplomatic.
I think my exact words were, "All right, well, you're getting
kicked off the island. Go ahead and like grab someone from downstairs.
Let's like the the idea being like let's get a rotation of people
in and out or something like that." But like I feel like I I
definitely should have like chaperoned him better through that.
But like the it was made worse by the fact that he was like,
"Do I have to leave?" Like like he was awkward about it. It was
like he was uncomfortable and I was like, "Oh, there's no going
back now." I think you actually just send him to go down and
hang out with like Cappy. I don't think you asked him to send
someone up. No, I definitely I either I went to go get someone
or I asked him to go get some. Yeah, I'm taking that. I'm taking
that position. That was my thought process. Let's Let's check
it out. Uh oh. Let's see. They're like, "Yeah, it's going to
be 120 bucks." And I was like, "What about the partner half price
discount?" And they're like, "That's with the discount." I was
like, "Kick that up, mate." God damn. What the is wrong with
you? Are you really yelling the [__] out of me about
that? Bill, you're getting kicked off the island. No, you should
go downstairs and hang out with uh with Gabby and all that. We're
going to talk about other stuff. What?
Oh, I did it. It's actually brutal. Oh, Cherry, you got it exact.
Jesus Christ.
Well, it wasn't go get somebody else. It was you're out of here.
We're going to talk about I definitely got up and went to like
try to get somebody else.
It is like a nice thing to hang out with Gabby. So, it's not
like that's like, "Oh, go hang out with the children." Gaby's
like fun fun happy.
Um, is that like the worst thing to say to somebody?
Chud Chud is either Yeah, it's not the worst. Chud is either
Yeah. Go ahead. Sorry. Oh, Chad is either two months like six
months before or after basically leaning into a camera and making
one of the most racist jokes that's ever been done on any progressive
YouTube channel ever. Okay. And he's offended by Supreme's lack
of talent here. He's just like, "What?" Wait, hang on a minute.
No, he did his face reveal at this event. He had not done a face
reveal at this point. Yeah. Yeah. It's just 6 months after. Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. Okay. All right. Well, yeah, I'm picking him off.
Why? That's fine. I want to say can I Sometimes it feels good
to hurt people. That's why. Yeah. use. You get worse and worse.
Just so you know, it gets worse for here. You're right. It did
get worse. Can't believe that. Yeah, I had the exact perfect
memory. And Supreme was like, "It wasn't that bad. Let me tell
you what really happened." I I gave you the option to wait. You
did want to wait. I think I got up to try and go find someone.
I remember being like, "Okay, we need to get like a rotation
of people."
But yeah, definitely. Yeah, this is not good. All right, let's
keep watching, mate. That's why it's a stream. Tell someone else.
You want to say your channel name before I go? Oh, yeah. It's
all good. That was kind of nice. No, you're not me. Just say
your channel name. It's uh it's Will. Will and Will and his channel.
Okay. Appreciate y'all. Cool. Thanks. Okay. Cheers, mate. I'll
come and catch up with you. Yeah. Take your time.
Uh I just feel like it gets worse. It gets worse. I remember
this now. I lean in and I'm like, you wanted me to do that. Don't
blame me. You people wanted me to do that. Oh, there's You're
lucky the clip ends there. Oh boy. But that ending makes it seem
like that's Chud's uh soft side coming out. He wanted to say
something nice to that guy before he walked away. He did. He's
like, "Holy [__] he's going to go jump and I'm going
to make sure it's not to do with me.
I'm not going to get named in the letter."
That's angry with Will. I don't know. I did not handle that well.
I did not handle that well. Okay, that's for sure. I didn't have
a problem. I think Will's a sweet kid. Yeah, that's all. I wouldn't
go that far. I don't know him. Yeah, he definitely had a turn
later on, didn't he? Um I can't even remember. I'm looking Oh,
this would be later on that night. Hold on. Let me see here.
I'm looking. We have another one. There's Will. That's a completely
different house. Okay, I see. But this is uh earlier in that
same thing. I'm looking to see if there's one that would clip
behind where you had Will. Well, there's Gappy. Gappy came up
at another point. Can't you click the clip and then go to the
rest of the stream? You can't cuz the stream's gone.
So, it's just clips.
Some old timey clips we're looking for. There's this one. That
might have been No, it's not. I'm sure at some point we could
find it. Somebody has that saved somewhere. Somebody's got that
stream saved. I doubt it. I doubt it. I don't I don't think I
had like dedicated people saving my streams. I don't think it
was ever that popular. Yeah, but I feel like somebody would have
saved.
Yeah, it's going to be like a re exception to it or something.
or people who dis like basically just people who really dislike
um Will which is spicy. Yeah. Also because what you said this
was Chad's first face reveal so somebody might have recorded
all of his uh first it wasn't that stream it was just earlier
that weekend. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. But yeah Ryzen was there as well.
Okay. Sorry I didn't mean to interrupt. I just wanted to no say
my piece on it. I'm not I don't have bad blood with Will or anything
like that. We don't have any beef. That was way better content
when you This has them talk talking after. Oh, like Chuck. Oh,
did you not time stamp? You didn't time stamp. Okay, hold on.
You timestamped earlier. Oh, I'll just I'll just message Queman
and ask him for this time stamp. Uh oh, no. No. Quan has VODs.
Yeah, I I'll ask him for the VOD then. Oh, the time stamp in
his stream. Gotcha. Gotcha. Yes, yes, yes. Yes. Uh here, I'll
I'll pull it up right now. We'll see. We'll see how this goes.
So, cheers to come talk to you.
Yes. Pretty cool, isn't it? Yeah. You're clearly a man.
All my money. Will's coming back with beer. You got hype train
turned off. Why? Was coming back with a beer. They talked for
a little bit. That's not my decision, mate. That's why it's a
stream. Tell someone else if you want to see. Well, you've got
Well, I'm sorry. You got to get out of it quick. We've got Longneck
backstage. He's coming on any moment. Long night, it's all good.
I have no idea. Might be. No, you're not me. Just say your channel.
No, you're there. Someone will backstage long.
Appreciate y'all. Okay. And he does it, too. And he doesn't even
stand by the I'm not going to promote myself. He He
comes in. He's like, "Will Andy brag." And
dude, why does a way of making people look so much more than
they are? Uh, no. Oh, he's pretty He's like pretty unequivocally.
I I agree with you. But
yeah, but it's like
it's like Quinn will put the 3D glasses on you so you could see
just how from like every angle. Yeah. Uh I just feel like we
need to be more intimate with
I'm sorry. Chud Chud does not know if he's Is that you would
have
mate was your stream? Listen, you already So, my understanding
is that after this moment,
Will just leaves. Okay. Will does not go and hang out with Gappy
like Supreme suggested. Apparently, Will just walks straight
out of the Airbnb and leaves.
Walks. How do you feel about that, Supreme? That you just totally
obliterated this guy's entire TwitchCon dream. I feel bad. I
feel I definitely feel like I didn't handle this well. I feel
guilty. What is that? Um, what does that feel like? What does
it feel like to feel guilt? Yeah. I don't know. It feels a little
vulnerable. I guess you don't know that feeling. You've never
been guilty. I just feel in here. I know the feeling. I'm just
seeing if your feeling is real. Oh, I see. No, I mean like whatever.
It's uh like I definitely thought about that later. I was like,
"Dang." Like literally later that night, I was like, "Dang, I
should definitely have been like found another way to put that."
Let's make Let's be clear. I wanted him to leave. Uh but you
know, like Yeah, I think that's real. Like I feel like a lot
of people had off feelings about Will around this time. He was
like a
big like Max fan, but like not like normal Max fan. Like Max
I want you my dad kind of Max fan or something like that. Like
I look up to you Mr. Girl. And I think that rubbed a lot of people
the wrong way for a long time. For me it had nothing to do with
that. Like it really was just okay this guy's been like sitting
on the stream for a while and he's kind of like you know we got
we got to keep like I don't know. He just didn't fit. He wasn't.
Yeah, you you thought he was a loser. You just made him leave.
Get the [__] out of here, loser. I get it. Holy [__]
This is a guy who screams about how ripped people are like eight
hours a day, and he feels so uncomfortable at watching how badly
Will got raped in front of him. Like, he's actually so uncomfortable.
It's insane. Will leaving the Airbnb is also not that weird.
I'm pretty sure he came back the next day. He lives he lived
in he lives in that city. Like, he was local to the Airbnb. Okay.
All right.
Fair enough. I should have just said like, "All right, well,
hey, why don't you go ahead and grab someone from downstairs?
Let's get a rotation of people going or something like that."
That was what I figured like later that I was like, "Dang, I
was like really mean to that kid." Or, you know, some combination
of like I did not mean for that to be that mean, but like a combination
of his reaction and Chud's reaction. Chud didn't help me out
here. No, Chud actually buried you. He made you look so much
worse. It's so funny. He's so uncomfortable. It's just one of
those things. It was just funny. And I remember it like so vividly
that I I think I was just watching streams like it was it was
pretty late cuz this is West Coast. I was pretty far east at
the time. Um so it was pretty late. I think it was like 2 a.m.
or something. I just remember this happening. I was dying
It was funny. It was a good lesson for me though, honestly. Like
I feel like in in showbiz in general, there's um there's like
an unwritten rule about good guesting and part of good guesting
is like knowing when to knowing when you're just like not fitting
into the conversation and gracefully just leaving, right? Um
like that sort of timing. But I kind of like understood the other
side of that too, which is like knowing good hosting. if it's
if somebody's overstayed, you know, if it's like past somebody's
time to leave, there are ways of handling that in a way that's
like a little more opaque to the audience and like joial and
friendly and stuff and like doesn't make them feel miserable,
which I think probably is what happened to Will here. Yeah, I
I think so. I think so. But I It's funny now. Listen, Will got
over it clearly. He's He's still alive. He's still kicking. It
wasn't It wasn't that
Uh Reuben Rubin, we did go over R. Kelly's overdose. We talked
about it a little bit. I don't know that there's much to go over,
unfortunately. Uh, it was just like a new story, right? It's
probably not like a video or anything. I don't think he wrote
a song about it yet. But you know what? If I had done that, we
wouldn't be talking about it today and I wouldn't be here talking
to you right now. So,
yeah, exactly.
Boom. Trapped in confinement. In confinement.
Oh, good times. I think it's so funny. Why did we Why do we even
bring this up? Why do we bring Will up? Like I don't actually
know remember and this is two days ago on Queman's stream. He
brought this up too. So this is like a flashbulb memory for Queen
too that like Will got absolutely obliterated by Chud and I didn't
know Quean at this point in time. I don't think I talked to him
about this. So this is just one of the funniest things I've ever
seen happen on a stream.
I don't know. Quumin's got something cooking because he was bringing
up rise. I think he posted a video about ryome recently and I
remember all that stuff. Wants to go over after some of the old
Twitch bowl people maybe. I have no idea. God, crazy stuff.
Okay, we're back to Lady Killer. Warren Smith.
I'm psyched. Something about Warren Smith made me think of Will
and his channel. I brought it up. Why did I bring it up?
Oh, wait. Holy Grow. What? Oh, what happened? I'll just wait
for them to type it. What? You go. You go. Oh, sure, sure, sure.
Oh, it was um I think we were talking about Chud Ops or something
like Chud and his ops. And I said, oh, he cut Will down and then
it was like, oh, wait, no, it was Supreme, right? Cuz Tommy was
saying Chud have fought with all of his old allies or whatever.
And then we moved from that to Oh. Oh, I was like, well, who
did he go after? Who did he actually have like a falling out
with? Will in his channel? Yeah. Yeah. Then if Ry is being brought
up as somebody that like, oh, Chud and Ry were fine. And then
what? Ryome cut him out. That I don't think it happened in that
direction. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I I think R I'm pretty sure Ryzen
was the one. Yeah. A couple of those people cut Chud out. Um
we watched that. Me and Queen watched that months ago. I can't
remember. You might have been here too, Cherry. It was like uh
we were watching Chud and some of the Twitch pole people them
all calling him poor. I was a I was a Twitch streamer around
the time when Ryzen started coming up. He was like a he was like
a Hassan viewer. So, the idea that him and Chud didn't last very
long as like friends, that doesn't surprise me. Yeah. Not shocking
to many people. Although, I don't know much about I shouldn't
say that. Not shocking to most people cuz I've heard Queen talk
about him, but I don't know anything about Ryome, so I should
be careful. I shouldn't talk. Also, back to did she cut only
what? Also, did Oh, never mind. Holy Grail didn't Holy Xrail
didn't have anything extra special.
All right. Okay. Back to Warren Smith. I'm going to hit play.
I'm going to probably get some water, use the bathroom. I'll
be right back, guys. We might end up listening to some random
on whatever talk for a while. So, good luck. Good luck. Good
luck. Good luck. I can pause if you need me to. Cherry, you just
say something.
Me that became a story within itself and it's led me to meet
and sit down Peterson, Joe Ro, some of the people that I most
respect. So, it's been quite an adventure and now I'm here with
you. There you go. There you go. And uh it I think I saw the
video in question. You were like having a conversation with a
student and just your Socratic method kind of asking questions.
Yeah, that's my favorite thing to do. It was about JK Rowling.
A student asked if my view of Harry Potter has changed given
JK Rowling's bigoted opinion and we just had a fiveminute exchange
and I didn't really think it was that
stand out or anything but you can't explain these. I don't know
why it did what it did but
Yeah. Yeah. Cool. Cool. And maybe for like the panelists and
the viewers who aren't familiar, it was about like JK Rowling
and some of the like trans comments she's made. Is that Yes.
Yeah. The claim was she's transphobic and I just asked for evidence
as you described with the Socratic method which I wasn't consciously
doing the Socratic method. That's my favorite thing to do is
just have conversations like this and my favorite rock and roll.
And were you like let go from your job or what? I was fired.
Oh, you were fired because of the video. because of the video
and the conversation you had. Yeah. A few months after that.
Yeah. Yeah. Crazy.
Wild wild stuff. Um we have another chat coming in here from
uh one sec. We got
method. Hello. Oh my god. Sorry, I'm back. Um dude, this guy
his video his JK Rowling video is the most transparently like
scripted video ever. And he still pretends that it like wasn't
fake. Unless he just reproduced it and like tried to make like
a cinematic version of it. It's like the most transparently scripted
video I've ever seen. I don't know why he pretends it's just
like a random combo. It's It's so goofy. Hold on. Let me see
if I can find it. JK Rowling
Warren Smith.
We find the original. I actually think I
doing this method as well. Why is this happening to me? Why is
this happening to me? I'm being socratic right now, guys. Why
is my Why is my life this way? It's unconsciously being Socratic.
Nothing. Existential crisises.
I listen. We've been streaming for a little while. Okay. I'm
trying to I've never been that funny. All right. Continue on.
Want to talk about JK Rowling. Is Is that So, what's going on
with that? What do you want to know? Uh
she's she's had a pretty controversial past. I just want to know
like where this is the video that got him canceled. By the way,
this is the video he's like, "Yeah, I just had this totally normal
conversation with a student. It was just a totally off-the cuff
normal conversation that normal people have, you know, with a
camera directly on my face with lighting. With literal lighting,
with literal lighting facing me that you can see in the reflection.
Totally normal random combo. Guys, what are your thoughts on
it? Like, do you still like her? Why does this feel like this
setup to like a a you know when they like sit you down and they
ask you questions but the person's like behind the camera? I
don't know. Do you want to share your experience? No.
Okay. You play the video. So, let's get specific though. Let's
define bigoted opinions. What opinions are bigoted? We're going
to treat this as a thought experiment. I'm not going to say what's
right or wrong or what way to think. The whole point is to learn
how to think, not what to think. Yeah. Yeah. So when you say
big, you you're you're starting with So already definitely he
definitely talks this way. When you hear him stream or do anything
like that, he definitely talks this way the whole time. Not weird.
The conclusion that given her bigoted opinions. Yeah. But first,
let's start with Also, I didn't grab a drink. Give me two seconds.
Does she have bigoted opinions? So when when you say bigoted
opinions, she has had a history of being extremely transphobic.
I've heard you've heard. So what can you give me an example?
If you look at her Twitter, I think you could see a few things.
Um, if you want, I could try and find See if you can find See
if you can find one. So, one of these tweets that she came out
with in 2019, she said, the classic the classic name anytime
Kelly's lied. Okay. Name any Sorry, no, not Kelly. Not Kelly.
Not Kelly Lav. Name anytime Lav's
Dress however you please. Call yourself whatever you like. Sleep
with anything.
Yeah. Yeah. Are you not Are you not going to say it? Yes, you
lied. You're a liar. No, that's like what she would say. Oh,
I lied. I lied. I lied. Clip. Got a clip.
Adult who will have you. How's she doing? Um live your um still
married. I did get sent uh somebody gave me a link to her Twitter.
That was just like a picture. Hold on. Hold on. I'll pull it
up for you now. He saved it. He's got it in the tab. I didn't.
Okay. It was just uh her as Lola Bunny.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Cool. Yep. Somebody sent
What the [__] It's such a goofy. Best life in peace,
but force women out of their jobs for starting that for stating
that is real. So, you find that bigoted? What do you find about
it was?
It was deemed transphobic.
Like I myself.
Do you find that transphobic yourself? Uh, I don't really have
an opinion on it, but I'm just going with what a lot of other
people have said. So, let's pause it. Let's not go with what
other people are saying. Let's try and Anyway, I prove my point
with this video. This is a clearly scripted video. Um, he literally
has lighting set up. It's so goofy. And Elon Musk is one of the
people dumb enough to believe this. Bite the bait, hook, line,
and sinker. and then retweet it and watch this guy's career in
the stratosphere. So,
it is what it is. All right, let's get back to Warren Smith telling
the story and whatever. And he writes, "Warren better keep it
G or chat's going to regul regulate." Okay, you know this, you
know the song reference here. Uh, thank you, man. Uh, Warren
G regul regulate. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There you go. Here we go.
We got uh Well done, Joseph. I loved it. Thank you, man. appreciate.
Thank you so much for the uh super chat. Really appreciate it.
All right, we're going to just dive right into uh some of my
pre-show notes here. Uh we're going to
let's see
one sec, guys. We have
uh is it Lyanna? Yes. Or Okay, I got it. Lyanna. Yeah. You said
after dating someone for 2 months, you guys went on a trip to
Bali together and he got your name tattooed on him. Correct.
Did you get matching or was it just what is that crazy? Bali
is in India.
No, I don't think so. Where's Bali? Isn't that where Bollywood
is? Uh, it's in Indonesia.
Uh, country. Province of Indonesia. Bali is in Indonesia.
Never traveling outside of the country with someone I've only
been with for two Um,
it depends on I think like depending on I feel like she's right
in that area where if it was like right before co everything
was so cheap, maybe you'd do it. Maybe think about it. Although
I don't know some people just aren't worried about that kind
of thing getting you know I don't actually And how long did you
uh how long were you dating him after? So that was my most recent
relationship. That was the uh we ended up dating for two years.
the two-year guy, but we were only dating for two months and
decided to go to Bali. I told I was like, "You do not have to
get my name tattooed. I actually advise you probably don't."
Um, but I kind of liked it. I was definitely like, "Sure." I
didn't get his back. So, I mean, it's He still has it. He still
has it? Oh, yeah. Oh, the guy you you you still hang out with
him? Yeah, he still has the tattoo. Do you think he still has
feelings? That's crazy, Chad. For you? No. Bro, he's got your
tattoo on. I mean, I mean, he'll never forget me until he get
What happened? Wait, what happened that you could just go, Wait,
yeah, he's still got it tattooed on him. Uh, yeah. Does he still
have feelings for you? No. No. What? What did she do to him?
Is it covered up? So, I was just going to say, is he talked about
getting it covered up? Oh, he said he has to. Cuz I always say
I'm like, "Oh, you're definitely seeing other What's up?"
Maybe he broke up with her. Yeah, but she she did something to
him. She's just like, "No, he doesn't have feelings at all. I
feel like that. I feel like you know you did some [__]
people and he's like I literally have your name on my thigh so
no I don't. How long ago you broke up? About a year ago and he
still has the name. Wow. Maybe he does still love me. I really
hope this person is ESL.
That she has to be like Russian or something, right? So no idea.
How how long ago you broke up? About a year ago
and he still has the name. Wow. Maybe he does still love me.
Looks like a child. Sounds like a child. I can see why Brian
brought her on. Do you guys Do you guys talk still like regularly
or do you guys regular? Yeah, as some kind of ESL uh Russian,
Eastern European. You guys hung out yesterday. Yeah, we hung
out yesterday. Oh, that's the one from yesterday. But I always
roast him for it. I'm like, "Yeah, you still have my name tatted."
Oh my goodness. I mean, he made that I told him not to get it.
That's
Is there like a heart around it or is it just the name? It's
just my name in person. Yeah, just Lyanna. Has he I mean, you
guys been separated for a year. Has he dated other women? Um,
yeah, definitely. Like seriously. And like, has he told you,
"Okay, I was on this date with this girl and she saw the tattoo."
Like, has he relayed to you stories about the tattoo as it relates
to dating new and other women? I haven't really asked. It is
on his thigh, so maybe as long as his pants stay on, like he
doesn't have to tell people. But yeah, I don't know. I haven't
asked. That's a good question that maybe I should ask.
Zoom more into Warren here. I don't know how to Bro, he is he
is just staring at her like unblinking staring at her across
right now. Yeah, I don't know how he is with the with the gamer
posture. He is staring daggers into her right now. Ask a good
question though. Maybe I should ask.
Well, he's getting defined
by this camera angle. By the way, you can tell how far forward
he's cringing his neck. I would give my I'll give my perspective
on that. If I'm gonna be dating a girl
and she has another man's name tattooed on her, I don't think
I could date her. Like I She could be like, "He's dead." Oh,
no. I haven't talked to him in 10 years. I'd be like, "You got
to get I can't I can't do it. Where where it's on the thigh?"
You said like in front like in his like on his thigh. I suppose
like the the location
feel like every woman should just like defensively get the get
some random guy's name tatted on them. Yeah.
Yeah. Cuz then you will easily weed out all insecure jealous
men.
Or you filter for them at first. The ones that would like accept
that and still want to date and be like, "Yeah, that's fine."
And so you you filter for them and you don't realize it. Do you
do you understand how much harder they're going to try for you
cuz they know that name is there trying to figure out how they
can get their name there? Maybe. I don't know. I'm not sure.
Don't worry. This isn't for you. Me and like the three women
who watch you were plotting. Okay. Okay. Good one. Good. Would
also impact it too. Like if it was like on the pubic like like
on the hip on the hip or on the butt. Oh, no way. I should have
told him to get it on his butt. That would have been funny. Oh,
you wait. Would he have done it? I mean, yeah, he was pretty
in love with me at that time, so maybe two months. Wait, two
months in? It's a red flag. Yeah, I don't know, guys. We're not
together anymore. Warren, how many uh Do you have Do you have
a tattoo of your any tattoos? I have one tattoo and it's North
Carolina. North North Carolina. Yeah, North Carolina. Okay, there
you go. Rocking around. My home state. Uh Warren, when you were
single, he just had like the state outline of North Carolina
tattooed on him. That's what that means. The shape of North Carolina
is tatted on his chest apparently. Wait, but North Carolina is
such a boring shape. Isn't it like just all square? Oh, no. It's
not that bad. No, it's okay. It's still not great though. What
the [__] Also has the name of it on there. It's like
not just the state, but also just says North Carolina. NC
Yeah, I don't know what this guy's doing. I don't know what he's
doing. Yeah. No, Chud's got it. Chud knows the Chud knows the
reaction we should have. Okay, that is the that is the appropriate
reaction. Would it have been a red flag for you if you were going
on a date with a girl or interested in pursuing something with
a girl and she had a tattoo
of another dude's name? Any name? No offense to anyone if anyone
has a tattoo with a name, but I I just think it's tacky because
like how what a riot would cause that thought process. You're
not thinking
no North Carolina is forever. Cherry North Carolina will never
go away. Have you Have you ever been to North Carolina?
No. Which probably warms my opinion. Dog state. Just like tumble
weeds. Absolutely nothing. No nothing there. Nothing going on.
Nothing positive about North
Okay. It's like it's like not exactly South Carolina. South Carolina's
got like really nice beaches. Okay. All right. And if you go
up then you've got like Virginia and then like DC is right there.
Just like North Carolina is the in between.
Okay. But they did have Michael play college basketball there.
So they have that going for them.
No, they don't. Okay. You're taking that, too? He played basketball
so he could get the out of North Carolina.